I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies.
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们要为你带来终极的《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。
Hello. Hey, good morning. Office, ladies. Hello. Hey, good morning. Did this episode make you want to buy a new suit? No, it did not. Did it make you want to throw a basketball into a fish tank and electrocute a bunch of fish? No.
你好。嘿，早安。办公室女士。你好。嘿，早安。这一集让你想买一套新西装吗？不，并没有。它让你想把篮球扔进鱼缸里，然后电死一堆鱼吗？没有。
Of course not. Did it make you want a lot of coffee? It did not. I did laugh at this episode. I laughed a whole bunch. Yeah. It is Suit Warehouse, Season Nine, Episode 11, written by Dan Graney and directed by Matt Sohn.
当然没有。它让你想要很多咖啡吗？也没有。我确实看了这一集笑出来了。我笑了好一阵子。是的。这就是《西装仓库》，第九季第11集，由丹·格拉尼编剧，马特·索恩执导。
Here's your summary. With Jim working out of town, Dwight enlists Clark's help to help play a father and son in order to land a new client. Daryl heads to Philly to interview with Jim's new company and Pam tags along. And finally, the arrival of a new Nespresso machine throws the entire office into a caffeinated state of chaos.
以下是剧情简介。吉姆在外地工作，德怀特寻求克拉克的帮助，两人假扮父子去拿下新客户。达瑞尔前往费城参加吉姆新公司的面试，帕姆也随行。最后，一台新奈斯派索咖啡机的到来让整个办公室陷入了咖啡因带来的混乱状态。
I mean, it was mayhem. They started taking the place apart. Literally. Mm-hmm. All right, fast was mayhem. They started taking the place apart. Literally. Mm-hmm. All right, fast fact number one. Like I said, this episode was directed by our very own Matt Sohn. Yes, you guys have heard us talk about Matt Sohn
我的意思是，那简直是一片混乱。他们开始把那个地方拆了。字面意义上的拆。嗯哼。好吧，快讯一。就像我说的，这一集是由我们自己的马特·索恩执导的。是的，你们听我们在节目中谈论马特·索恩
for years on the show. Oh yeah, he's been with us since the beginning. Matt was also the one that knew you were pregnant when you thought you were fooling everyone. Yeah, he said, Jenna, I look at you through a camera all day long. I could see all of it happening. Yes, and he's also a father of two. Yes.
谈了好几年了。哦，是的，他从一开始就和我们在一起。当大家都以为自己瞒过了所有人时，马特也是那个看出你怀孕了的人。是的，他说，珍娜，我整天都通过镜头看着你。我能看出这一切都在发生。是的，他也是两个孩子的父亲。是的。
So he knew the signs. So I actually reconnected with Matt recently and he, Jenna, he hikes, he goes on all these hikes. I know he recently went on a hike with Chris Haston, who is Kate Flannery's longtime boyfriend and our NBC photographer. goes on all these hikes. I know, he recently went on a hike with Chris Haston, who is Kate Flannery's longtime boyfriend and our NBC photographer, and David Denman. The three of them went on a big old hike recently.
所以他知道那些迹象。所以我最近其实和马特重新联系上了，他，珍娜，他去远足，他参加所有这些远足活动。我知道他最近和克里斯·黑斯廷斯一起去远足了，克里斯是凯特·弗兰纳里的长期男友，也是我们的NBC摄影师。他去参加所有这些远足活动。我知道，他最近和克里斯·黑斯廷斯一起去远足了，克里斯是凯特·弗兰纳里的长期男友，也是我们的NBC摄影师，还有大卫·登曼。他们三个最近一起去进行了一次大型远足。
Oh yeah, so he said to me, I should wanna go for a hike. And I was like, yes. No. But you don't want that. He goes so fast. He's like, he's like sporty. And as it came time for the hike, I really lucked out because we got all that rain. Remember LA just got like a downpour
哦，是的，所以他对我说，我应该去远足。然后我说，好啊。不。但你其实不希望那样。他走得太快了。他就像是，他很喜欢运动。到了远足的时候，我真的很走运，因为我们遇到了所有的雨。还记得洛杉矶刚刚下了一场倾盆大雨吗
of rain. Yeah. And so I was like, how are those hiking trails looking with my fingers crossed? He goes pretty muddy. And he said, want to do a neighborhood walk? I said, yes. Yes. Oh, you lucked out. I lucked out. And you know, we're neighbors. So we live in the same neighborhood. Yeah. So we just went on this wonderful walk and he let me point out flowers and different like awnings I like. He didn't go too fast. He didn't go too fast. It was a stroll. Nice. Anyway, Matt is wonderful. And on this walk, we were talking about the podcast and he was saying how much he's enjoying it.
雨。是的。所以我当时怀着忐忑的心情问他，那些远足小径现在怎么样了？他说，挺泥泞的。然后他说，想在附近社区散步吗？我说，好啊。好啊。哦，你太幸运了。我很幸运。你知道，我们是邻居。所以我们住在同一个社区。是的。所以我们只是去散了这趟美妙的步，他让我指出我喜欢的花朵和不同的遮阳篷。他没有走得太快。他没有走得太快。这只是一次漫步。不错。总之，马特太棒了。在这次散步中，我们聊到了播客，他说他有多么享受这个节目。
He said, you know, when you get to Suit Warehouse, I would love to share with you some behind the scenes details. And I said, Matt, we will 100% hit you up for that. And he was so gracious. He sent us in a ton of audio clips for this episode. He did, and they're great. He has some good details.
他说，你知道，当你讲到《西装仓库》那一集时，我很乐意与你们分享一些幕后细节。我说，马特，我们100%会找你聊这个的。他非常大方。他为这一集给我们发了大量的音频剪辑。他确实这么做了，而且非常棒。他有一些很好的细节。
So buckle in for that. All right, fast fact number two, Building Athlete. Yes. This was a big episode in so many ways, but one of the biggest things in this episode is that we revealed Jim's new business for the first time. His swanky new office. I know and it's really impressive Steve Burgess said we spent a very long time designing it and it was expensive He said but we were able to spread the cost over a bunch of different episodes. Mm-hmm So some sneaky budgeting I guess we also asked Matt zone about being an athlete for the first time and Having to direct this new space. And here's what he had to say.
所以大家系好安全带准备收听吧。好了，快讯之二，建设运动员（Athlead）。是的。这在很多方面都是重要的一集，但其中最大的一件事就是我们首次揭开了吉姆的新公司的神秘面纱。他那间时髦的新办公室。我知道，而且真的令人印象深刻。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说，我们花了很长时间来设计它，而且造价昂贵。他说，但我们能够把成本分摊到许多不同的剧集里。嗯哼。所以我想这是些偷偷摸摸的预算操作。我们还问了马特·索恩关于第一次担任运动员（Athlead）导演以及不得不执导这个新空间的感受。以下是他的说法。
This episode established the athlete offices. They were built on our lot in our warehouse set. I believe Matt Flynn was the production designer at this time. He had taken over for Michael Gallenberg. Athlete was built to look just the opposite of the Dunder Mifflin set. It had high ceilings, lots of windows and nice views.
这一集确立了运动员公司的办公室。它们是在我们的外景地、我们的仓库布景中搭建的。我相信马特·弗林当时是制作设计师。他接替了迈克尔·加伦伯格。运动员公司的布景被建造得与邓德米夫林的布景截然相反。它有高高的天花板、大量的窗户和不错的视野。
It had exposed brick and the set design was also much hipper. There were cool desks, chairs and artwork. It was an alluring place for both Jim and Daryl. I feel like the crew only had a few weeks to build this set, and I think they were a little bit behind because we ended up having to shoot the scenes there at the end of our episode, you know,
它有裸露的砖墙，而且布景设计也更加时髦。那里有很酷的桌子、椅子和艺术品。对吉姆和达瑞尔来说，这是一个诱人的地方。我觉得剧组只有几周的时间来搭建这个布景，而且我认为他们的进度有点落后，因为我们最后不得不把那里的场景安排在我们那一集的末尾拍摄，你知道的，
to make it fit within our schedule. You know, it didn't really occur to me how kind of not great the Dunder Mifflin office space is until Matt started describing the athlete of high ceilings, lots of windows. Alluring. Yeah, I was like, oh, yeah. Well, Jenna, Matt's own mentioned Matt Flynn. And you know, I had reached out to Matt Flynn when we broke down pool party to get all the details about Robert California's swanky pool house.
为了让它符合我们的拍摄日程。你知道，直到马特开始描述运动员公司那高高的天花板和大量的窗户时，我才真正意识到邓德米夫林的办公空间其实有点不那么理想。诱人。是的，我当时想，哦，是的。好吧，珍娜，马特·索恩提到了马特·弗林。你知道的，当我们剖析《泳池派对》那一集以获取罗伯特·加利福尼亚时髦的泳池屋的所有细节时，我曾联系过马特·弗林。
Yes. And that's two swankies, Dr. Thibodeau. I've already said swanky twice. But anyway, so Matt Flynn told me when you get to the fancy athlete offices, I want to share about it. And so here's what he had to say about building that set. Ooh, I'm very excited. I'm leaning in.
是的。那是两个“时髦”，蒂博多医生。我已经说过两次“时髦”了。不过总之，马特·弗林告诉我，当你们讲到那个高档的运动员公司办公室时，我想分享一下相关情况。以下是他对搭建那个布景的看法。哦，我太兴奋了。我探过身子去听了。
All right, I quote, "'This story arc gave the art department "'a great opportunity to show how many changes "'had occurred in the workplace since the office first aired. "'Slick and with much less clutter, "'textured with a completely different color palette, "'no stacks of file boxes in the corners, "'a reliance of laptops and with much less clutter, textured with a completely different color palette, no stacks of file boxes in the corners, a reliance of laptops rather than clunky old equipment like
好的，我引述他的话：“这个故事线为美术部门提供了一个绝佳的机会，来展示自《办公室》开播以来，职场发生了多少变化。圆滑且杂物少得多，以完全不同的色彩搭配呈现出质感，角落里没有成堆的文件箱，更多依赖笔记本电脑，且杂物少得多，以完全不同的色彩搭配呈现出质感，角落里没有成堆的文件箱，更多依赖笔记本电脑，而不是那些笨重的旧设备，比如
fax machines, for example. And we were able to show the athlete office space in a couple of episodes where it was being converted from a raw, unfinished, and maybe even a little spooky environment, allowing us to get a grip on Jim's anxiety about making such a big career change. Wow, I love all this detail. Oh, there's more! Matt Flame goes on to say, a couple of things stand out as this set came together. Early discussions had found the need for a separate conference room unnecessary, keeping the space more open and less cubicle-like, another contrast from Dunder
传真机。我们能够在几集节目中展示运动员公司的办公空间，当时它正从一个毛坯、未完工甚至可能有点吓人的环境改造过来，这让我们能够体会到吉姆对于做出如此大的职业转变的焦虑。”哇，我喜欢所有这些细节。哦，还有更多！马特·弗林接着说，当这个布景逐渐成型时，有几件事格外突出。早期的讨论发现，没有必要设立一个单独的会议室，从而使空间保持得更加开阔、更少隔间感，这与邓德米
Mifflin. Then there were changes in the script that did indeed require for a separate space for meetings and more private encounters. Well, there was no such space in this now almost finished and decorated space. Wow. They built the whole thing without a conference room. So all these scenes that happened with Daryl at the interview were kind of like a late-breaking idea.
夫林形成了又一个对比。然后剧本发生了变化，确实需要一个独立的空间来进行会议和更私密的交谈。好吧，在这个现在几乎完工并装饰好的空间里，并没有这样一个空间。哇。他们建造整个地方时居然没有会议室。所以所有这些达瑞尔在面试时发生的场景，其实有点像是一个临时起意的主意。
That's right. Matt goes on to say, Our wonderful art director, Yvonne, knew every square inch of Stage 2, having drafted and laid out numerous configurations of scenery over several seasons, and she realized that behind one wall of the newly built athlete office was 12 feet of unused space. Wow. So if we pushed that wall back and added some sliding glass doors, we could maybe now accommodate a conference room. And with the great construction crew and scenic artists we relied on, it could be camera ready in under 48 hours. You know what blows my mind is that most of the scenes at Athlete end up taking place in this little room that they added in 48 hours. Yeah. This extra little 12 feet of space. Thanks to Yvonne for knowing every square inch of that space.
没错。马特接着说，我们出色的艺术总监伊冯娜熟悉2号摄影棚的每一平方英寸，她曾为多个季度绘制和规划过无数种布景配置，她意识到新搭建的运动员公司办公室的一面墙后面有12英尺未使用的空间。哇。如果我们把那堵墙往后推，再加一些推拉玻璃门，我们现在可能就能容纳一个会议室了。凭借我们信赖的伟大施工团队和布景艺术家，它可以在48小时内就准备好进行拍摄。你知道让我大吃一惊的是什么吗？运动员公司的绝大多数场景最终都发生在这个他们用48小时加出来的小房间里。是的。这多出来的12英尺空间。多亏了伊冯娜对那个空间的每一平方英寸都了如指掌。
Yeah. Matt goes on to say, another addition to the set, which we were mindful of keeping on budget, was a steel stairway leading to an unseen upper floor of athlete office space. Late in the process, my construction coordinator, Tim James, crunched the numbers and yes,
是的。马特接着说，对布景的另一个改动是通往运动员公司办公室未露面的楼层的一座钢制楼梯，我们在设计时非常注意控制预算。在后期，我的施工协调员蒂姆·詹姆斯计算了数字，是的，
we could afford to add that element in the background. Significantly helping increase the sense of scale to the space and we added some animation as employees were able to come down the stairs. It might seem an insignificant element, but we took great pleasure when it was installed again in about less than 48 hours. Okay, I completely noticed that staircase. Same. And I loved it.
我们负担得起在背景中加入这个元素。这显著增强了该空间的规模感，并且随着员工们走下楼梯，我们还加入了一些动态效果。这可能看起来是一个微不足道的元素，但当它再次在不到48小时内安装完毕时，我们感到非常高兴。好吧，我完全注意到了那个楼梯。我也是。我很喜欢它。
And it did feel like, I don't know, everything, it felt bigger, it felt more important, it felt more energized. Yeah. Wow. Thank you, Matt Flynn. We love those behind the scenes details. I loved them. Thank you, Matt.
而且它确实给人一种，我不知道，一切都感觉更宏大、更重要、更有活力。是的。哇。谢谢你，马特·弗林。我们喜欢这些幕后细节。我很喜欢。谢谢你，马特。
And Matt. Thank you, Matt and Matt. All right, moving on to fast fact number three, I want to give a big shout out to Ed Lauter, who played Mr. Stone of Stone and Son Suit Warehouse. He was fantastic. He is a film and television legend. He is a prolific character actor. We were so lucky to have him on our show.
还有马特。谢谢你们，两位马特。好了，接下来是快讯之三，我要对扮演“斯通与子西装仓库”的斯通先生的埃德·劳特尔表示诚挚的谢意。他太棒了。他是电影和电视界的传奇人物。他是一位高产的性格演员。我们非常幸运能邀请他出演我们的节目。
He passed away in 2013 and The Office was one of the last things he worked on. He was also a recurring character on Shameless at the time and he had filmed a couple of movies that came out after he had passed away. He worked as a stand-up comedian before getting into film. He appeared in more than 200 film and television episodes over his 40-year career. He was in four films with Charles Bronson. He was in Death Wish 3, Death Hunt, The White Buffalo, and Break Heart Pass. He was also in an Alfred Hitchcock film called Family Plot.
他在2013年去世了，《办公室》是他参与的最后几部作品之一。他当时也是《无耻之徒》中的常驻角色，并且他还拍摄了几部在他去世后上映的电影。在进入电影界之前，他曾是一名单口喜剧演员。在他40年的职业生涯中，他参演了200多部电影和电视剧。他曾与查尔斯·布朗森合作过四部电影。他参演过《猛龙怪客3》、《野地追踪》、《白水牛》和《断心关》。他还出演过希区柯克的电影《大侦探（家庭阴谋）》。
And he appeared in three films that were nominated for Best Picture. He was in Born on the Fourth of July, Seabiscuit, and The Artist, and I found this interview that he did in 2003 and it had a quote that I was completely charmed by. He said, quote, someone said to me, Eddie, you're a turn actor. That's when a story is going along and your character shows up and the story suddenly takes a major turn. I love that. I love that term turn actor.
他曾参演过三部获得奥斯卡最佳影片提名的电影。他出演过《生于七月四日》、《奔腾年代》和《艺术家》，我找到了他在2003年做过的一次采访，里面有一句话让我完全着迷。他说，引述如下：“有人对我说，埃迪，你是一个转折演员。那是当故事正在进行时，你的角色出现，然后故事突然发生了重大转折。”我喜欢这个。我喜欢“转折演员”这个词。
Yeah, I do too. I've never heard that before. And you know exactly that moment when you watch a movie when everything shifts. Yep. Like someone comes to town and there's information dropped and you're like, uh-oh. Yeah. That's a great term. I love it.
是的，我也喜欢。我以前从未听说过这个词。当你观看一部电影时，你非常清楚那个一切都发生转变的时刻。是的。就像有人来到镇上，透露了一些信息，然后你会想，哦哦。是的。这是一个伟大的词。我很喜欢。
Well, I just wanted to honor him, his body of work, and he was great on our episode. Yeah. All right, well, that's all I've got for Fast Facts. Well, why don't we take a break? Because when we get back, Dwight is gonna get a new instant message. Old tech alert.
嗯，我只是想向他致敬，向他的作品致敬，他在我们这一集里的表现非常棒。是的。好吧，这就是我所有的快讯了。那么，我们为什么不休息一下呢？因为当我们回来时，德怀特将会收到一条新的即时消息。旧科技警报。
It is the oldest instant message I've ever seen. I know. We are back and like you said, this episode is going to start with some old tech. Dwight is at his computer and a bright red message box pops up in the lower right-hand corner says, new instant message. It's from David Wallace. And that Stone and Sons Suit warehouse contract with their paper supplier expired. David Wallace is like, go get it. Yeah.
这是我见过的最古老的即时消息。我知道。我们回来了，正如你所说，这一集将从一些旧科技开始。德怀特坐在电脑前，右下角弹出一个亮红色的消息框，上面写着：新即时消息。来自大卫·华尔es。而斯通与子西装仓库与他们纸张供应商的合同到期了。大卫·华尔斯的意思是，去把它拿下来。是的。
Dwight has a talking head where he explains that he and Jim had a tradition whenever they were pitching to family-owned businesses, they would pretend to be brothers. And they did this for a law firm, they did it for a construction company, for a motorcycle store. I have a costume breakdown. Oh yes, because they would dress the part. They sure did. For their family-owned law firm, they both wore very nice suits, much nicer than they normally wear, and they slicked back their hair. Yeah. A little bit of a Gordon Gekko, Wall Street moment happening. Then when they were a family construction company, they wore flannel t-shirts, they wore flannel button-downs, Dwight wore a hard hat, Jim carried his hard hat, but then
德怀特有一个面对镜头的独白，他解释说他和吉姆有一个传统，每当他们向家族企业推销时，他们就会假装是兄弟。他们为一家律师事务所这样做过，为一家建筑公司这样做过，为一家摩托车店这样做过。我有一份服装解析。哦，是的，因为他们会穿上符合身份的服装。他们当然这么做了。为了他们的家族律社，他们都穿了非常漂亮的西装，比他们平时穿的好得多，而且把头发向后梳理。有点像戈登·盖克、《华尔街》那种时刻。然后当他们是一家家族建筑公司时，他们穿了法兰绒T恤，穿了法兰绒衬衫，德怀特戴着安全帽，吉姆带着他的安全帽，但随后
had like a messy hair look. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, because when you're a paper salesman selling to a construction company, it makes sense that you bring a hard hat? None of it makes sense. None of it makes sense. Then for a family owned motorcycle store, and this is the most elaborate costume, they wore black leather pants, black jackets,
弄了一个头发蓬乱的造型。是的。是的。是的，因为当一个推销员向建筑公司推销纸张时，带一顶安全帽是合理的吗？这完全说不通。这完全说不通。然后对于一家家族摩托车店，这是最精致的服装，他们穿着黑色皮裤、黑色夹克、
boots and helmets, and they had a motorcycle. Dwight also goes on to say that their names were Jim and Dwight Schrupert. And Dwight says, I was the dynamic likable winner that was doted on by mom and Jim was the closeted foot fetish pretending to belong. Of course, the client never knew any of that, but I knew it. And Lady? What? Oh my God, is Dwight doing that actory thing where he gives himself a backstory
靴子和头盔，他们还有一辆摩托车。德怀特接着说，他们的名字叫吉姆和德怀特·舒珀特。德怀特说：“我是那个充满活力、讨人喜欢、备受妈妈宠爱的赢家，而吉姆是一个隐蔽的恋足癖，假装自己属于这里。”当然，客户从来不知道这些，但我知道。而女士？什么？哦，天哪，德怀特是不是在做那种演员的事情，给自己一个背景故事
to motivate his sales character? Sounds like it. Sounds like he did a little Jenna acting journal. He did, sounds like he had a little document for himself. That cracks me up. I love how the backstory of their brotherhood can travel from scenario to scenario. Oh, yeah. The Schrueperts.
来为他的销售角色提供动力？听起来是这样。听起来他做了一点珍娜式的表演日志。他确实这么做了，听起来他为自己准备了一份小档案。这让我笑死。我喜欢他们兄弟关系的背景故事如何在不同的场景之间转换。哦，是的。舒珀特兄弟。
Mm-hmm. Well, Dwight is giddy. He calls Jim, and I loved this whole exchange. It was great. He says, I hope you've been paying your wig storage bills, Jimbo. How many wigs, how many costumes do they have? Well we know Dwight has a lot because he pretended to be people in the office. That's true, that's true.
嗯哼。好吧，德怀特欣喜若狂。他打电话给吉姆，我喜欢这段完整的对话。太棒了。他说：“我希望你一直在支付假发储存账单，吉姆博。”他们有多少顶假发，有多少套服装？好吧，我们知道德怀特有很多，因为他在办公室里假装过其他人。那是真的，那是真的。
Well Jim reminds him, I am not there. I'm in Philly, I'm not going to drive to you and go on the sales call, get someone else, maybe Phyllis can pretend to be your sister. And Dwight says, Phyllis, my sister? More like my dead great-great-grandmother who died of stupidity. And Phyllis goes, I have ears, Dwight. And then Dwight's response to me is like an 11-year-old boy on the playground. He goes, oh, really, Phyllis, you have ears like all human beings. Well, we asked Matt Sohn about this cold open, and here is what he had to say.
好吧，吉姆提醒他，我不在那儿。我在费城，我不会开车去找你并去进行那个销售拜访的，去找别人吧，也许菲利斯可以假装是你的姐姐。德怀特说：“菲利斯，我的姐姐？更像是我那个因愚蠢而死去的死去的曾曾祖母。”菲利斯说：“我有耳朵，德怀特。”然后德怀特对我的回应就像操场上一个11岁的男孩。他说：“哦，真的吗，菲利斯，你和所有人类一样拥有耳朵。”好吧，我们向马特·索恩问起了这个片头冷笑话，以下是他的说法。
I have a handful of funny memories from the episode. The run at the beginning of the show that has Jim and Dwight in the different outfits playing brothers was great when they're walking out of the front of Dundermiflin. But the one that had us laughing the most was when Rain and John are both in full leather apparel and on the back of the motorcycle.
我对这一集有一些有趣的记忆。节目开头让吉姆和德怀特穿着不同服装扮演兄弟的桥段很棒，当时他们正走出邓德米夫林的正门。但最让我们大笑的是雷恩和约翰都穿着全套皮衣坐在摩托车后面的时候。
Something I noted from that moment was that they never take off. Oh yeah. They just rev it. He's just revving it. Oh, yeah. You never see that motorcycle move. I'm sure Steve Burr just was like, we're not paying insurance for these guys to be on a
我从那个时刻注意到的一件事是，他们从来没有开走。哦，是的。他们只是轰油门。他只是在轰油门。哦，是的。你永远看不到那辆摩托车移动。我确信史蒂夫·伯吉斯当时的想法是，我们可不付保险费让这俩家伙一起骑
motorcycle together. Angela, we got a very interesting fan question from this cold open from Sean K in Lisbon, Wisconsin. Sean says, at one minute, 23 seconds, when Dwight is mocking Phyllis, you can clearly see Angela yawning a huge yawn. Long day sitting at the desk in the background or just life? I saw it. Sean, did you see it?
摩托车。安吉拉，我们从这个片头冷笑话中收到一个非常有趣的粉丝提问，来自威斯康星州里斯本的肖恩·K。肖恩说，在1分23秒时，当德怀特嘲笑菲利斯时，你可以清楚地看到安吉拉打了一个巨大的哈欠。是因为在背景中坐了一整天办公桌太累了，还是仅仅是生活？我看到了。肖恩，你看到了吗？
Yes, I saw it. I was so embarrassed. I was so embarrassed. I clearly was just really tired because it's a really big yawn. Yeah, one minute, 23 seconds, everyone. It was an early morning. I missed it the first time. All right, so now this episode is going to begin,
是的，我看到了。我太尴尬了。我太尴尬了。我显然只是真的很累，因为那是一个非常大的哈欠。是的，1分23秒，各位。那是个清晨。我第一次看时漏掉了。好了，现在这一集要正式开始了，
and Darryl enters the bullpen. He's dressed up real spiffy. And we find out he is heading to Philly for his interview with Athlead. Pam wishes him good luck, and then Darryl says, why don't you just come with me? And she realizes that their office has no manager and there are absolutely no consequences to her leaving for the entire day. Yeah, I thought about this too, because I don't think normally when you're at a job that you would announce to everyone that you're
达瑞尔走进员工大办公室。他打扮得很精神。我们发现他正前往费城参加运动员公司的面试。帕姆祝他好运，接着达瑞尔说：“你为什么不跟我一起去呢？”然后她意识到他们的办公室没有经理，而且她离开一整天也绝对没有任何后果。是的，我也想过这一点，因为我觉得通常在工作时，你不会向所有人宣布你
going to look for another job. I know. Like, could you imagine like coming in, in like a suit and whatever and here and being like, guys, I'm looking for, could you imagine, like, coming in in, like, a suit and whatever and here and being like, guys, I'm looking for another podcast. Bye or something. Yeah, exactly. On that note, Angela, in the next scene, a taxi is going to pull into the parking lot and Clark gets out. He's carrying a duffel bag.
要去找另一份工作。我知道。就像，你能想象穿着西装什么的来这里然后说，伙计们，我在找……你能想象穿着西装什么的来这里然后说，伙计们，我在找另一份播客吗？再见或者什么的。是的，正好。顺便说一句，安吉拉，在下一个场景中，一辆出租车将驶入停车场，克拉克走了下来。他提着一个大旅行袋。
He's arriving back to work after being away with Jan. Yeah. So I have two questions for you. Okay. Number one, why did Daryl even come into the office today? Why did he stop by just to leave? And second, why does everybody come to the office after returning for a trip? From a huge trip with their luggage.
他结束了与简的外出后回到工作岗位。是的。所以我有两个问题要问你。好的。第一，达瑞尔今天为什么还要来办公室？他为什么特意顺路过来却又要离开？第二，为什么每个人在旅行归来后都会来办公室？从带着行李的一场巨大旅行归来。
With their luggage. He didn't want to stop at home. Yeah, I know. And also, like, Daryl didn't want to just leave from home? Darryl is the only one I can wrap my brain around, because what if he was like, OK, I've got to do a few last minute things in the office, then I'm hitting the road?
带着他们的行李。他不想先回家。是的，我知道。而且，达瑞尔难道不能直接从家里出发吗？达瑞尔是我唯一能理解的人，因为如果他说，好吧，我得在办公室处理一些最后的事情，然后我就上路了，那会怎么样？
Sure. OK. But coming back from the plane straight to Dunder Mifflin in the morning. Yeah. What was this flight? I don't know. A red eye? Yes, it was a red eye. But yes, Angela, you're right. Maybe Darryl stopped in he did like an hour of emails. Yeah. And then he took off. Then he left. But anyway, Pam is going to go with him. Yeah. This is is gonna be fun. Speaking of Clark, everyone is really happy to see him back.
当然。好吧。但坐完飞机清晨直奔邓德米夫林。是的。这到底是什么航班？我不知道。红眼航班？是的，那是红眼航班。不过是的，安吉拉，你是对的。也许达瑞尔顺路过来处理了一个小时的电子邮件。是的。然后他就出发了。然后他就离开了。不过总之，帕姆要跟他一起去。是的。这
Dwight says, oh, Dwight Jr's back. And Kevin wants to know how it went down with Jan. This talking head is so funny to me. It's so brilliant. I had to put in all caps, oh my gosh, Clark Duke crushes this talking head. I went to the candy bag alts, there were none. This was it.
会很有趣。说到克拉克，大家看到他回来都非常高兴。
Don't need them. Don't need them. It's perfect. This is what he says. A gentleman doesn't discuss such matters, especially when the feelings of a lady are involved. Women reached their sexual peak at whatever age Jan was last week.
德怀特说，哦，小德怀特回来了。凯文想知道他和简之间发展得怎么样了。这段独白对我来说太有趣了。太精彩了。我不得不全部用大写字母写下来，哦天哪，克拉克·杜克这段独白太绝了。我去看糖果袋有没有备用，结果没有。就是这个。
It's such a funny line. That is such a funny line. I mean, it was like making love with a wild animal, but not like a cougar, like you might think. It was like a swarm of bees. And then this line got me, bees that just find something wrong with every hotel room. That is such good writing.
不需要了。不需要了。太完美了。他是这么说的。绅士不讨论这种事情，尤其是涉及女士的情感时。女性会在简上周所处的任何年龄达到她们的性高潮巅峰。
That is such good writing. Oh my gosh. Like, as an actor, when you get handed that piece of writing, you are giddy. You cannot wait to do that talking head. Yeah. And Clark does such a great job. Meredith is going to chime in and say, talk classy, act nasty. That's what her mom used to say. That's right.
这真是一句好笑的台词。这真是一句好笑的台词。我的意思是，那就像是与野生动物做爱，但不是像你想象的那种美洲狮。那就像是一群蜜蜂。然后这句台词击中了我的笑点：蜜蜂只是对每个酒店房间都能挑出毛病。这编写得太棒了。
Motherly advice. And this is when Clark clocks that her hair is totally different and asks her if she has a wig on and Meredith is like, oh, is it on backwards? And then she lifts it up and adjusts it. You can see the bald cap underneath. For that three second joke, maybe it's two seconds. Kate had to come in at 330 in the morning and get that bald cap put on. Three hours to get that on. Yep.
这编写得太棒了。哦天哪。就像，作为一个演员，当你拿到这样一段台词时，你会欣喜若狂。你简直迫不及待地想要演这段独白。是的。而且克拉克演得太棒了。梅雷迪思插话说道，言谈要高雅，举止要风骚。那是她妈妈常说的话。没错。
And yes, Meredith is a brunette this week. Guess what? Clark has a gift for the office. It's from Jan. Yeah, apparently on the Amalfi Coast, Jan and Clark drank a lot of espresso. They became fond of it. So Jan has sent Clark back to the office
母亲的忠告。也就是在这个时候，克拉克注意到她的发型完全变了，问她是不是戴了假发，梅雷迪思说，哦，是戴反了吗？然后她把假发掀起来调整了一下。你可以看到底下的光头套。为了那个三秒钟的笑话，也许是两秒钟，凯特不得不早上3点30分赶到片场戴上那个光头套。花了三个小时才戴好。是的。
with a new Nespresso machine as a gift. Oscar is so delighted. We got a fan question from Maddie R in Dallas, Texas who said, the way Phyllis and Oscar talk about the Nespresso machine and the way the box is perfectly facing the camera makes me think that this was a paid product placement, was it? And if so, how did this come about? Well, we asked Matt Sohn about this and here's what he had to say. On a fun side note, Phil Shea, our prop master, again scored for us. He was able to get Nespresso to sign off and let us use one of their actual machines and their name, which is surprisingly more rare than not.
是的，梅雷迪思这周是个黑发女郎。你猜怎么着？克拉克给办公室带了礼物。是简送的。是的，显然在阿马尔菲海岸，简和克拉克喝了很多浓缩咖啡。他们迷上了这种咖啡。所以简派克拉克带着一台新的奈斯派索咖啡机作为礼物回到了办公室
Usually you have to make up a name for a product. But they were excited about the script and they loved the episode. Yes, Angela. Steve Burgess said that once Phil got permission from Nespresso, they still had to get NBC sales to sign off on it because we were basically giving Nespresso a free commercial. This was not paid product placement. This was us writing an episode and just asking permission to use their machine.
。奥斯卡非常高兴。我们收到了来自德克萨斯州达拉斯的Maddie R的粉丝提问，他说：菲利斯和奥斯卡谈论奈斯派索咖啡机的方式以及咖啡机盒子完美面向镜头的方式，让我觉得这是一次付费产品植入，是这样的吗？如果是的话，这是怎么谈成的？好吧，我们问了马特·索恩关于这件事的说法，以下是他的回答。顺便说个趣事，我们的道具大师菲尔·谢伊又立功了。他成功让奈斯派索签字同意让我们使用他们的一台真实机器以及他们的品牌名称，这surprisingly比平时要罕见得多。
And Steve Burgess said they were a little reluctant because, you know, it was just like free advertising, but they did say okay. Oh yeah, NBC I'm sure was like, show me the money. Cause it is, it's like an amazing ad forever. I know, it's true. And Maddie is right, that box is placed perfectly on reception and we see this machine throughout the whole episode. Well, it sounds like they were office fans and I just think it's great. I'm
通常你必须为产品虚构一个名字。但他们对剧本很兴奋，而且他们很喜欢这一集。是的，安吉拉。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说，一旦菲尔得到了奈斯派索的许可，他们仍然必须让NBC销售部门签字批准，因为我们基本上是在给奈斯派索做一个免费广告。这不是付费产品植入。这是我们写了一集剧本，然后只是请求许可使用他们的机器。
glad that they said yes. Well we got more fan mail about Nespresso from Carrie L in Stillwater, New Jersey who said, I don't have the full breakdown of Nespresso but I do want to tell you that they are big on recycling and when you're done with your coffee capsules, they come to me. I work at a food waste management warehouse in New Jersey named AgChoice. Not only that, but my specific job is the manager of our program Capsule Connections. I work with local high school students with disabilities on gaining job skills. We have 12 schools and close to 70 students in a work-based learning program
而且史蒂夫·伯吉斯说他们有点勉强，因为，你知道，这就像是免费广告，但他们确实同意了。哦，是的，NBC我确信当时的想法是，把钱拿出来。因为这确实是一个永远生效的惊人广告。我知道，这是真的。Maddie说得对，那个盒子完美地放在前台，我们在整集中都能看到这台机器。好吧，听起来他们是《办公室》的粉丝，我只是觉得这太棒了。我
who help us recycle these each day. And the coffee then goes to our local compost site to turn into topsoil. It's an amazing job with some great hardworking students plus the perks of coffee. Carrie says, be sure to use the free recycling bags from Nespresso and it will get shipped to us and be recycled properly and stay out of a landfill. Thank you, Carrie. Yeah, I love that. I did a little mini deep dive on this and I watched a bunch of videos and I was seeing this recycling program and this real attempt to be more environmentally conscious. It was really cool. So when you get Nespresso,
很高兴他们答应了。好吧，我们收到了更多关于奈斯派索的粉丝邮件，来自新泽西州斯蒂尔沃特的Carrie L，她说：我没有奈斯派索的完整解析，但我确实想告诉你们，他们非常重视回收，当你用完咖啡胶囊后，它们都会送到我这里来。我在新泽西州一家名为AgChoice的食物垃圾管理仓库工作。不仅如此，我具体的工作是我们的“胶囊连接”项目的经理。我与当地有残疾的高中生合作，帮助他们获得工作技能。我们有一个工作学习项目，涵盖12所学校和近70名学生，
because I don't have one, it comes with the little recycle bag, and then you send that back. Yeah, and so you save your pods, and you don't have to clean them out. You don't have to separate them. You don't have to do anything. You just put them in the bag, I guess. I mean, according to these videos,
他们每天帮助我们回收这些东西。然后咖啡渣会被送到我们当地的堆肥场变成表土。这是一份了不起的工作，有一些勤奋刻苦的学生，还有咖啡带来的福利。Carrie说：一定要使用奈斯派索提供的免费回收袋，它会被运给我们并得到妥善回收，从而远离垃圾填埋场。谢谢你，Carrie。是的，我喜欢这样。我对此做了一点微型的深入研究，我看了很多视频，我看到了这个回收项目以及真正想要更加环保的努力。这真的很酷。所以当你买奈斯派索时，
and then you send it, and then it all gets taken care of. They separate it. They recycle it. They do all of it. That's great. I know. Yeah, I just really liked Carrie's letter, and it all gets taken care of. They separate it, they recycle it, do all of it. That's great. I know.
因为我没有，它会附带一个小回收袋，然后你把它寄回去。是的，所以你攒下你的咖啡胶囊，你不需要把它们清理干净。你不需要把它们分开。你不需要做任何事。我想你只需要把它们放进袋子里。我的意思是，根据这些视频，
Yeah, I just really liked Carrie's letter because I loved how much she loved her job. I always love when people love their job. I also love to learn about new jobs. Now that Clark is back, Dwight's will's are turning. He sees a new opportunity here for a sales team, and he goes back to the Annex and he says, you know what, Clark, you did a great job in helping us land those white pages. How would you like to be Dwight Jr.
然后你寄出去，所有事情就都处理好了。他们会把它们分类。他们会回收。他们把所有这些都做了。太棒了。我知道。是的，我真的很喜欢Carrie的信，所有事情就都处理好了。他们会把它们分类，回收，做所有这些。太棒了。我知道。
and pretend to be my son to help me land a sale? Clark says, if it helps me break into sales, I'll do it. Yeah, Clark is wanting to climb the old corporate ladder. That's right. Get out of the annex. Yeah. Meanwhile, in the kitchen, everyone's enjoying the new Nespresso machine.
是的，我真的很喜欢Carrie的信，因为我喜欢她那么热爱自己的工作。我总是很喜欢人们热爱自己的工作。我也喜欢了解新的工作。既然克拉克回来了，德怀特的心思又活络起来了。他在那里看到了销售团队的新机会，他回到附楼说：你知道吗，克拉克，你在帮我们拿下黄页广告方面做得太棒了。你愿不愿意当小德怀特，假装是我的儿子来帮我拿下这笔业务？克拉克说：如果这能帮我进入销售部，我愿意。是的，克拉克渴望往上爬旧的公司阶梯。没错。离开附楼。
But we have a little awkwardness in the kitchen. Erin and Pete enter. And I think Erin is still kind of reeling from the whole lice thing, from the whole head massaging and all of that. Well, I think so. She's very self-conscious. She's very self-conscious.
与此同时，在厨房里，每个人都在享受新的奈斯派索咖啡机。
Also, though, we missed one thing we should bring up, which is, I mean, before Pam left, she said, Erin, just so you know, we're gonna get a shipment of pins today. And Erin's like, what do you mean? What do you mean shipment of pins? I haven't been trained for this. She starts to spiral and Pam's like, ha, okay.
但我们在厨房里遇到了一点尴尬。艾琳和皮特进来了。我想艾琳可能还没从虱子事件中缓过神来，从头部按摩和所有那些事情中。好吧，我想也是。她非常自我意识过剩。她非常自我意识过剩。
I can't believe we didn't mention it because it's one of my all-time favorite scenes. It's so funny to me. Yeah, but this detail has completely overwhelmed Erin the character. Ellie does such a great job with it. But Erin's gonna have a talking head where she says, you know what, I have a lot going on right now
不过话说回来，我们漏掉了一件应该提一下的事，那就是，在帕姆离开之前，她说：艾琳，顺便说一句，我们今天会收到一批大头针（别针）货。艾琳说：你什么意思？你什么意思指大头针货？我没有为此接受过培训。她开始情绪失控，帕姆说：哈，好吧。
with the pen shipment, and I don't have time to think about Pete, you know? I have a lot of people like counting on me and I don't wanna break anyone's trust about the pens. Yeah. You know, there would have been a Pete talking head that would have come right after Aaron's. Oh.
真不敢相信我们没提到它，因为这是我最喜欢的场景之一。这对我来说太搞笑了。是的，但这个细节把艾琳这个角色彻底压垮了。艾莉演得太棒了。但艾琳会有一个面对镜头的独白，她说：你知道吗，我现在有很多事情要处理，
It's in the deleted scenes. And Pete is basically saying, I thought things were going well, but I don't know. Maybe something happened. Maybe I said something that offended her, but I couldn't have said anything more offensive than anything anyone else says here in the office. And he says he's been like playing over the conversations in his head to try to figure it out. I know. Sweet Pete. Sweet
关于大头针的货物，我没有时间去想皮特，你知道吗？有很多指望我的人，我不想辜负任何人对大头针的信任。是的。你知道，本来应该有一个皮特的独白，紧跟在艾琳的独白后面。哦。
Pete. We love him. Mm-hmm. Well in the next scene, Daryl and Pam are driving to Philly together and Daryl's nervous. Yeah, and Pam is going to try to comfort him. She's like, listen, this is a tiny startup with a bunch of dorky guys like Jim. He can't be scared in a room full of Jims. She's like, I love him, but he's basically Gumby with hair. And they kind of have a laugh. And once again, it's clear to me that Pam doesn't know anything about Jim's life in Philadelphia. Wouldn't he have shared with her about the office, photos, anything, how it's coming along?
它在被删减的场景里。皮特基本上是在说，我以为事情进展得很顺利，但我不知道。也许发生了什么。也许我说了一些冒犯到她的事，但我说的话绝不可能比办公室里其他人说的任何话更具冒犯性。他说他一直在脑海中反复回放那些对话来试图找出原因。我知道。可爱的皮特。可爱的
I mean, you know, I know I joked in the lice episode that I kind of fall apart if Lee goes out of town and maybe I don't share completely with him all of my stress of him being gone because I don't wanna burden him with that, I don't want him to feel guilty or whatever. But at the same time, like, I do know what's going on with him and he knows what's going on with me. He knows I don't do well when he's gone. This is not a secret in our marriage. And similarly, like, I can hold that he's off doing
皮特。我们爱他。嗯哼。好吧，在下一个场景中，达瑞尔和帕姆一起开车去费城，达瑞尔很紧张。是的，帕姆要安慰他。她说：听着，这是一个只有一堆像吉姆那样的书呆子的小型初创公司。他不可能在一屋子吉姆面前害怕。她说：我爱他，但他基本上就是一根带头发的冈比（Gumby）。他们俩笑了笑。再次向我表明，帕姆对吉姆在费城的生活一无所知。难道吉姆没有跟她分享过关于办公室的事、照片、任何进展吗？
an exciting thing while I'm dumping trash on the street. Like, you know, and so it's hard for me to relate to this idea that, like, Jim hasn't, I don't know, like, shared photos of the office in an excited way, like that he's not sharing his excitement over this opportunity with her. Yes. And it's been weeks. So I just think about the little home remodel that we did, you know? And how when I had to go out of town, the week that like the floors went in, Josh sent me pictures, floors are going in. It's exciting. Oh my gosh, we got faucets today. You know what I mean? Yes.
我的意思是，你知道我知道我在虱子那一集里开过玩笑，如果李出城了，我就会有点崩溃，也许我不会跟他完全分享他不在身边的所有压力，因为我不想给他增加负担，我不想让他感到内疚什么的。但与此同时，我知道他在发生什么，他也知道我在发生什么。他知道他不在的时候我过得不好。这在我们婚姻里不是秘密。同样的，我可以接受他去进行一件令人兴奋的事情，而我在街上倒垃圾。你知道，所以我觉得很难理解这种想法，就像吉姆没有，
And I feel like- But also, also he probably shared the frustrating parts with you too. Like, floors went in today, they showed up three hours late and didn't have all the materials. Like I'm making that up. But I'm saying like, sure, the whole process gets shared. That's what I'm saying. That's what I have a hard time with. They invested $10,000 of their savings that along the way over these weeks where construction
我不知道，比如没有以一种兴奋的方式分享办公室的照片，或者他没有跟她分享他对这个机会的兴奋之情。是的。而且已经好几周了。所以我只是想到了我们做的那个小型家居改造，你知道吗？当我要出城时，铺地板的那一周，乔什给我发了照片，地板正在铺。这太令人兴奋了。哦天哪，我们今天有水龙头了。你知道我的意思吗？是的。
was happening that there wasn't like a photo of like, hey, look, we now have a logo on the conference room door. We're official. Are we weird? I mean, that's what we would do. I don't think we're weird. I don't know. Sorry to go off on that, but I just couldn't believe that Pam had no idea what this office
我觉得——但还有，他可能也跟你分享了那些让人沮丧的部分。比如，今天地板铺好了，他们迟到了三个小时，而且没有带齐材料。我这是瞎编的。但我是说，整个过程都会被分享。这就是我想说的。这就是我难以置信的地方。他们投资了10,000美元的储蓄，在这些星期的施工过程中，居然没有一张照片，比如，嘿，看，我们的会议室门上现在有标志了。我们正式了。难道我们很怪吗？我的意思是，那是我们会做的事。我不觉得我们怪。不知道。抱歉扯远了，但我实在无法相信帕姆对这个办公室长什么样一无所知。
looked like. Well, she's about to walk in and find out and she is surprised. Sorry to go off on that, but I just couldn't believe that Pam had no idea what this office looked like. Well, she's about to walk in and find out and she is surprised. Should we jump to that? Pam and Daryl arrive and she is clearly surprised. I want to read you how the scene was described in the shooting draft. Lady! What? I have the same thing. You did?
好吧，她马上就要走进去亲眼看到了，而且她会大吃一惊。抱歉扯远了，但我实在无法相信帕姆对这个办公室长什么样一无所知。好吧，她马上就要走进去亲眼看到了，而且她会大吃一惊。我们应该跳到那个部分吗？帕姆和达瑞尔到达了，她显然很惊讶。我想给你读读拍摄剧本中是如何描述这个场景的。女士！什么？我有一样的东西。你也有？
Yes, because there is a big moment that got cut out of Pam and Darryl's arrival, and I remember having to shoot the whole thing. Go ahead, read the description. Okay. Pam and Darryl step out of the elevator and into Athlead. The place is bustling as they make their way up to the receptionist, who is on the phone. The receptionist smiles and holds up a finger to say, one minute, please.
是的，因为在帕姆和达瑞尔到达的过程中有一个被剪掉的大场面，我记得当时必须把整段都拍下来。来吧，读一下描述。好的。帕姆和达瑞尔走出电梯，进入运动员公司办公室。这里一派繁忙，他们朝着正在打电话的前台走去。前台微笑着举起一根手指，示意请等一分钟。
There are two big leather armchairs and a coat rack. Pam and Daryl look around at the energetic, fashionably hip employees. Pam's old puffy parka, and then in parentheses it says from taking out the trash episode, is super dorky in comparison to their sleek looks. She takes it off and hangs it on the coat rack where it covers the leather jackets that were already hanging on it. Daryl, making light of the fancy armchairs, bows formally to Pam and gestures for her to have a
那里有两个大的皮革扶手椅和一个衣帽架。帕姆和达瑞尔环顾四周，看着那些充满活力、时尚时髦的员工。帕姆那件臃肿的羽绒大衣，然后括号里写着来自扔垃圾那一集，相比他们时髦的外表显得超级滑稽。她脱下大衣，把它挂在衣帽架上，正好盖住了已经挂在那里的皮夹克。达瑞尔拿那些豪华扶手椅开玩笑，正式地向帕姆鞠躬并示意她请坐。
seat. They both sit and watch the energy. Pam looks for Jim. Ready for this? Jim enters from the back hall with a client. They walk towards reception. The client is tough and Jim's all business. They approach Darryl and Pam. Pam starts to smile and give a wave, then thinks better of it. Jim winks at her. at her. Mm-hmm. Yeah, so most of all of that got cut, but we got a fan question from Luke M. in England who said, at the eight minute mark, Jim greets Daryl and Pam at athlete,
两人坐下，观察着这里的活力。帕姆寻找吉姆。准备好了吗？吉姆和一个客户从后面的走廊走了进来。他们朝着前台走去。客户很强硬，吉姆全神贯注于业务。他们走近达瑞尔和帕姆。帕姆开始微笑并挥手，然后又打消了这个念头。吉姆向她眨了眨眼。朝着她眨眼。嗯哼。是的，所以绝大多数都被剪掉了，但我们收到了来自英格兰的卢克·M的粉丝提问，他说：在8分钟大关，吉姆在运动员公司迎接达瑞尔和帕姆，
and he says goodbye to Dennis, who then awkwardly searches for a coat behind Pam and then just disappears. What was that? Well, that was, if you look close, Pam's giant puffer coat is covering all the other coats on the coat rack because of this long entrance that ended up getting cut. Yes. The script went on to describe that moment saying that this awkwardness of Pam's coat
他跟丹尼斯道别，然后丹尼斯尴尬地在帕姆身后寻找一件外套，接着就消失了。那是什么？好吧，那是，如果你仔细看，帕姆那件巨大的羽绒大衣因为这个最终被剪掉的长镜头出场，把衣帽架上的其他外套全都盖住了。是的。剧本接着描述了那一刻，说帕姆的外套带来的这种尴尬感
covering the sleek coat was all part of making Pam feel like she was out of place. And I don't know if you noticed my wardrobe in this episode, but it was very intentional that I'm wearing kind of one of my older sweater shirt combos. One, we said Pam didn't know she was going to take off from work and go visit gym. And two, we really wanted to try to contrast her with the way the people at Athlead were dressed. That's right. Well, we should probably go back
Pam大衣那种利落的款式，完全是为了让她显得格格不入。我不知道你们有没有注意到这集里的服装，我穿的那件旧毛衣和衬衫的搭配，其实是刻意安排的。一方面，我们说过Pam并不知道自己会翘班去探望Jim；另一方面，我们真的很想在视觉上形成对比，衬托出她跟Athlead公司里那些人的穿着有多不一样。没错。好吧，我们可能该回去了
because Dwight and Clark are over at Stone and Son. But before we do, I just wanna give a shout out to guest star Ross McKenzie, who played Dennis, the man looking for his coat. Oh my gosh, what has Ross not been in? He has been in Scrubs, ER, New Girl, Grey's Anatomy, Veep, Modern Family, Mad Men, Arrested Development, and Monk. Hey, Monk crossover.
因为Dwight和Clark正在Stone and Son父子西服店。但在我们回去之前，我只想感谢一下客串演员罗斯·麦肯齐（Ross McKenzie），他饰演了寻找大衣的男士丹尼斯（Dennis）。天哪，罗斯演过多少作品啊？他演过《实习医生风云》（Scrubs）、《急诊室的故事》（ER）、《杰茜驾到》（New Girl）、《实习医生格蕾》（Grey's Anatomy）、《副总统》（Veep）、《摩登家庭》（Modern Family）、《广告狂人》（Mad Men）、《发展受阻》（Arrested Development）和《神探阿蒙》（Monk）。嘿，梦幻联动！
At Stone and Son, the owner is delighted to be meeting a father and son paper company. Dwight and Clarky are really trying to bond with Mr. Stone. They're talking about hunting. I want to give a shout out to Set Design because Mr. Stone's office is perfect. And so specific. So specific. I became obsessed with it.
在Stone and Son，老板非常高兴能接待一家做纸业生意的父子。Dwight和Clark真的很努力想跟斯通先生（Mr. Stone）套近乎。他们聊起了打猎。我要给布景设计点个赞，因为斯通先生的办公室简直完美。而且细节太到位了。太到位了。我都对它着迷了。
So many details. Well, there's one detail that we got a piece of fan mail about. This is from Angela C. in Grove City, Ohio. Angela asked, is the mallard on Mr. Stone's desk the same one that Dwight used to bug Jim's office? Well, Angela, I looked it up. I did a side by side.
有太多的细节了。对了，有一个细节我们收到了一封粉丝来信。这是来自俄亥俄州格罗夫城的安吉拉·C（Angela C.）发来的。安吉拉问：斯通先生桌上的那只绿头鸭，是不是当初Dwight用来整Jim办公室的那只？好吧，安吉拉，我查过了。我做了个对比。
So did I. It's not the same. It's not the same. We'll put it in stories. But Angela C. went on to say, I wish I knew someone with a podcast who would want to do a deep dive on mallard ducks. I did not do this.
我也是。不是同一只。不是同一只。我们会把它发到限时动态里。不过安吉拉·C接着说，要是我认识哪个做播客的人，愿意深入研究一下绿头鸭就好了。我可没这么做。
I did this. I did this, Angela C. I did this, Angela C. First of all, I just want you guys to know there is a fantastic website called allaboutbirds.org. I highly recommendbirds.org. I highly recommend it. Okay. And they give a great mallard overview.
我这么做了。我做了，安吉拉·C。我做了，安吉拉·C。首先，我只想让大家知道，有一个非常棒的网站叫allaboutbirds.org。我强烈推荐allaboutbirds.org。我强烈推荐它。好吧。而且上面对绿头鸭有很棒的概述。
So when I grew up in St. Louis, Missouri, my parents had and still have a cabin at Lake of the Ozarks, tons of mallard ducks. I know a few things. Well, last year I had a mallard that came and stayed with us for about two weeks in our swimming pool. Did you have a pair or a single? I had a single then a lady joined. Well you know, here's the thing I know about them. They mate for life. Well I have some things that are gonna rock you to your core. Oh my
所以当我小时候在密苏里州圣路易斯长大时，我父母在奥沙克湖（Lake of the Ozarks）有一座小屋（现在还在），那里有成吨的绿头鸭。我还是懂一点的。好吧，去年有一只绿头鸭来我们的游泳池待了大约两周。你遇到的是一对还是一只？我先是一只，后来加入了一只雌的。好吧，你知道吗，关于它们我了解的是，它们一生只认一个伴侣。好吧，我有些事情要彻底震撼你。噢，天哪！
gosh! Go ahead. Okay, according to allaboutbirds.org, mallards are perhaps one of the most familiar of all the ducks in North America and Eurasia. The male's gleaming green head, gray flanks, and black tail make it very distinguishable. And chances are if you have a pond or marshy area on your property, mallards might be attracted to your backyard. Occasionally mallards have been known to show up in people's swimming pools. Yes, that is true. Here are some stats for you, though. Are you ready?
说吧。好吧，根据allaboutbirds.org的说法，绿头鸭可能是北美和欧亚大陆所有鸭子中最常见的一种。雄鸟那闪闪发光的绿色头部、灰色的侧腹以及黑色的尾巴，让它极具辨识度。如果你家的领地上有一个池塘或沼泽地，绿头鸭可能会被吸引到你的后院。偶尔还有人发现绿头鸭会出现在人们的游泳池里。是的，这千真万确。不过，这里有一些数据供你参考。准备好了吗？
Okay. Mallard stats. Mallard pairs are generally monogamous, but paired males pursue females other than their mates. Wait a second. Mm-hmm. I will continue. So-called, quote, extra pair copulations are common among birds and in many species are consensual. But male mallards often force these copulations, with several males chasing a single female and then mating with her.
好。绿头鸭数据。绿头鸭配偶通常是一夫一妻制，但结了婚的雄鸭也会追求伴侣之外的雌鸭。等一下。嗯哼。我继续说。所谓的，引号，“配偶外交配”在鸟类中很常见，而且在许多物种中是双方自愿的。但雄性绿头鸭经常强迫这种交配，几只雄鸭追逐一只雌鸭，然后与她交配。
Oh my God! They have their main lady, but then they have this side s*** going down. Oh my gosh! I did not know this! Yeah. This is really bumming me out! I know! Ugh. Okay, what else do you have? Mallard ducks are strong flyers. Migrating flocks of mallards have been estimated traveling
噢，天哪！它们有正室，但同时还在外面搞这种偷腥的勾当。天哪！我居然不知道这个！是啊。这真的让我太沮丧了！我知道！呃。好吧，你还有什么？绿头鸭是飞行高手。据估计，迁徙中的绿头鸭群飞行速度
at 55 miles per hour. Wow. The standard ducks quack as the sound of a female mallard. Males don't quack. They make a quieter, raspy sound. Interesting. This I know from my two weeks with my mallards because the male just swam around, he swam around, and then the lady showed up and it was like, wah, wah, wah. Like she was so loud and super chatty. She's probably yelling at him about all the side stuff he's up to when he goes out. Yeah.
可达每小时55英里。哇。标准鸭子的“嘎嘎”声其实是雌性绿头鸭的叫声。雄鸭不叫“嘎嘎”声。它们发出的是一种比较安静、沙哑的声音。有趣。这些是我跟我那两只绿头鸭朝夕相处两周得知的，因为那只公鸭就到处游，到处游，然后母鸭出现了，听起来就像是，呱，呱，呱。就像她声音特别大而且极其唠叨。她可能在冲他发火，数落他在外面干的那些偷腥的勾当吧。对。
The oldest known mallard was a male and at least 27 years and seven months old when he was shot in Arkansas in 2008. Are you ready for this? What? It goes on to say he had been banned in Louisiana since 1981. How do you get banned?
已知最长寿的绿头鸭是一只雄鸭，2008年在阿肯色州被猎杀时，它至少已经27岁7个月大了。你准备好听这个了吗？什么？上面接着说，它自1981年起就在路易斯安那州被禁了。你怎么会被禁呢？
How do you get banned? What did he do? As a mallard from the whole entire state. What did they do? Did they move him? I don't know. From Louisiana to Arkansas? There was no more information.
你怎么会被禁的？它干了什么？作为一只绿头鸭，被整个路易斯安那州禁止。它们干了什么？它们把它移送了吗？我不知道。从路易斯安那州移送到阿肯色州？没有更多信息了。
How did they check this? I don't know. I'm sure he was tagged. I was tired. I really wanted to get into the banned Louisiana mallard. Lady, you're not leaving that there and moving on. I know. The band Mallard.
它们是怎么查出来的？我不知道。我敢肯定它被做过标记。我当时很累。我真的很想深入了解这只被路易斯安那州禁止的绿头鸭。大姐，你不能就这么把这事撂这儿然后翻篇啊。我知道。这只被禁的绿头鸭。
I know. I know. I was tired. I will definitely find out why the Mallard was banned. Yes, you will. There will be a part two. Meanwhile, there is a duck and waterfowl ID course online. You can get training in identifying waterfowl from all angles and take your bird skills to the next level with Bird Academy. I don't care at all about Bird Academy. I just wanna know why this mallard,
我知道。我知道。我当时很累。我一定会去查清楚那只绿头鸭为什么会被禁。没错，你会的。还会有第二集。与此同时，网上有一个鸭子和水鸟识别课程。你可以通过鸟类学院（Bird Academy）接受从各个角度识别水鸟的培训，把你的观鸟技能提升到新的水平。我一点也不关心鸟类学院。我只想知道为什么这只绿头鸭，
and then he was shot by a hunter? He was shot in Arkansas in 2008, but he'd been banned from Louisiana Since 1981. All right, clearly I have some more deep diving to do but Angela see there you go all about birds org is a site for you to check out my childhood lake of the Ozark self Who had this? I, I'm sorry. By this new information about the male mallard duck.
然后它被一个猎人给枪杀了？它于2008年在阿肯色州被枪杀，但自1981年起它就被路易斯安那州禁了。好吧，很显然我还有更多深入的研究要做，但是安吉拉·C，你看，allaboutbirds.org就是个适合你去看看的网站。我童年记忆里的奥沙克湖本人，竟然……我，我很抱歉。关于雄性绿头鸭的这些新信息，
Sorry. I now see them totally differently. I had this romantic like they mate for life, look at this loving couple, like they're gonna grow old together, little duckies. I had no idea. Yeah, I'm sorry. Even when you and I were trading messages, you were like, oh, Mallard's made for life. I have stories. I was like, oh, this isn't gonna go over well for her. Well, there you go, everybody. All right. Mom detectives are gonna to go on the case of the band
抱歉。我现在对它们的看法完全变了。我以前对它们抱有那种浪漫的想法，比如它们一生厮守，看看这恩爱的一对，就像它们会一起慢慢变老，小鸭子们。我真的一无所知。好吧，我很抱歉。甚至当你在跟我发信息的时候，你还说，噢，绿头鸭一生只认一个伴侣。我还有很多故事呢。我当时就想，噢，她听到这个肯定要大跌眼镜了。好吧，大家听到了吧。好啦。妈妈侦探们要出动去侦破被禁绿头鸭之谜了。
Mallard. The Louisiana band Mallard. What have I got? I can give you a little bit about this location of Stone and Son. Yeah. Matt Stone sent in an audio clip, and this was a very unique location.
路易斯安那州的禁令绿头鸭。我有什么要说的？我可以向大家介绍一下斯通和儿子（Stone and Son）这个取景地的一些情况。好的。马特·斯通（Matt Stone）发来了一段音频，这是一个非常独特的取景地。
I'll let him tell you why. To my knowledge, this was the only episode in the entire nine seasons of the show that we shot in Hollywood. The suit warehouse store that we used was a shop on Hollywood Boulevard. We only had one exterior shot. I think that's just Dwight and Clark walking out and down the street. But the rest of the shoot was done
我让他来告诉你们原因。据我所知，这是全剧九季中唯一一处我们在好莱坞实地拍摄的场景。我们使用的服装仓库店其实是好莱坞大道上的一家店。我们只有一个外景镜头。我想那就是Dwight和Clark走出来并顺着街道走的那段。但其余的拍摄都是
in the interior of that location. This story was fun because it gave Clark Duke a meaty story to dig into, and he really had fun with the episode. Well, I followed up with Matt because I was shocked that we shot on Hollywood Boulevard in season nine. They just sent Dwight Schrute walking down the street. I said, what happened? Did this cause a stir? You guys, Hollywood Boulevard is so congested. There's
在该取景地的内部完成的。这个故事很有趣，因为它给克拉克·杜克（Clark Duke）提供了一个可以深入发挥的丰满故事，他在这一集里演得真的很开心。好吧，我和马特进行了后续交流，因为我大为震惊，我们在第九季居然是在好莱坞大道上拍摄的。他们只是让Dwight Schrute走在街上。我说，发生什么了？这引发轰动了吗？各位，好莱坞大道太拥挤了。有
so many tourists. It's that walk of, you know, the walk of fame, the stars. It's, it's so full of people. Yes. Matt said they didn't have a problem. They shot that exterior shot in a window. They didn't have anybody bother them. All those people who flew in from out of town, they probably had no idea that the office was shooting right there as they were walking by looking at the stars on the street.
那么多的游客。那就是星光大道，有很多星星。人实在是太多了。是的。马特说他们没有遇到什么麻烦。他们透过一扇窗户拍摄了那个外景镜头。没有人去打扰他们。那些从外地飞来的游客，当他们边走边看街上的星星时，可能根本不知道《办公室》剧组就在他们身旁拍戏。
Crazy, crazy. Oh lady, I think we should take a break. And when we come back, everyone is trying the Nespresso and they are going to make a pact. Yeah, because you know what? What? YOLO! YOLO! We are back and pretty much everybody who is still at Dunder Mifflin is in the kitchen
太疯狂了，太疯狂了。噢，天哪，我觉得我们该休息一下了。等我们回来，每个人都要尝尝Nespresso咖啡，他们还要订下一个契约。对，因为你知道吗？什么？及时行乐（YOLO）！我们回来了，几乎所有还在邓德米夫林（Dunder Mifflin）的人都在厨房里
and they are buzzed on this coffee. Yeah. Oscar suggests that they try every flavor because how else are they going to know which one is their favorite? Everyone's super receptive to this idea. Everyone is going to agree. They're going to put their hands in the middle and they're going to do that thing where they're like, we agree.
他们都被这咖啡给弄得亢奋了。是的。Oscar建议他们把每种口味都尝一遍，因为不然他们怎么知道哪一种才是他们最喜欢的呢？大家对这个想法都超级接受。每个人都表示赞同。他们会把手叠在中间，然后做那种表示“我们同意”的动作。
We make a pact. Yes. Angela doesn't want to put her hand in the middle. She's like, can I just agree without putting my hand in the middle? Yeah. She grabs a napkin. She puts the napkin on the pile of hands and she puts her hand on top. They all say, we all drink them all.
我们订下契约。是的。Angela不想把手叠在中间。她就像是：我能不能只表示同意，不用把手叠在中间？好吧。她抓了一张纸巾。她把纸巾盖在那堆手上，然后把她的手放在最上面。他们一起说：我们全都把它们喝光。
We all drink them all. At the end, Phyllis's ring is missing. Creed has clearly taken it. He's like, I'm sure it'll turn up. We got a fan question from Martha B. and Malta who said, was Angela licking her fingers before grabbing the napkin scripted or something you came up with Angela. I thought it was a very Angela thing to do. I did that.
我们全都把它们喝光。最后，Phyllis的戒指不见了。Creed显然把它拿走了。他就像是：我确信它会自己出现的。我们收到了来自马耳他（Malta）的玛莎·B（Martha B.）的粉丝提问，她说：Angela在抓纸巾之前舔手指头是剧本里写的，还是你自己即兴发挥的，Angela？我觉得这非常符合Angela的作风。是我自己加的。
That was not scripted. So the only thing in the script was that Angela places a napkin on top of everyone's hands and puts her hand on top of it. That's all that was in the script. But when we were filming, I had to quickly grab the napkin and walk over and they were sticking together. So I would go to grab one and there'd be like a few.
那不是剧本里写的。所以剧本里唯一的内容是，Angela把一张纸巾放在所有人手的上方，然后把她的手放在最上面。剧本里就只有这些。但我们在拍摄时，我必须迅速抓起纸巾走过去，结果它们粘在一起了。所以我伸手去抓一张的时候，会抓上来好几张。
So I licked, I didn't even know that I had done it. I licked my fingers to separate the napkin. And yeah, that was me. You know, there's a lot of behavior from Angela around germs that as we watch it post pandemic doesn't seem as odd. Like oh, you know? Like I am very aware of like shaking hands now or putting my hands in a pile.
所以我舔了舔——我甚至都不知道自己这么做了。我舔了舔手指来把纸巾分开。然后，是的，那是我的主意。你知道，Angela在对待细菌方面有很多行为，我们在后大流行时代回看时，会觉得没那么奇怪了。就像，噢，你懂的？比如我现在对握手或者把手叠在一起都非常警惕。
Right? I think we all are. Yeah. I mean, I have hand sanitizer everywhere. Like if I go to the grocery store, I get in the car, I spray my little hand sanitizer. Were you always like that? No. Right. I'm saying Angela Martin was ahead of the curve.
对吧？我想我们所有人都是。是的。我的意思是，我到处都放着免洗洗手液。比如我去杂货店，一上车，我就喷一下我的小免洗洗手液。你一直都这样吗？没有。对吧。我的意思是Angela Martin走在了时代的前沿。
Yep. Back at Suit Warehouse, Dwight sends Clark to go get a brochure from the car. And that's when Mr. Stone reveals that he doesn't have such a great relationship with his own son. Yeah. Dwight's like, oh no, we've got to change gears here.
没错。回到服装仓库，Dwight打发Clark去车里拿一份宣传册。就在那时，斯通先生透露了他跟自己的儿子关系其实并不怎么好。是的。Dwight心想：噢不，我们得转换策略了。
So when Clark comes back in, he's like, what were you out there smoking pot, you idiot? Like he's like, Clark's like, what is happening? He kind of whispers, we don't have a good relationship. So they have to pivot. Yeah, Clark catches on. So now Clark starts giving it back. Yeah, this takes a real turn. It really does.
所以当Clark走回来时，他就像是：你刚才在外面抽大麻了吗，你个白痴？就像他那样。Clark一脸懵：发生什么了？他压低声音耳语道：我们关系不好。所以他们必须转变方针。是的，Clark心领神会。于是Clark也开始回嘴了。是的，这来了个大转弯。确实如此。
I have to say in this scene, which was very funny, I couldn't help but notice a detail on Mr. Stone's desk. It was very distracting to me, I think maybe for personal reasons. Did you see the number of fresh brand new pencils with full erasers that were in Mr. Stone's pencil cup? Yes, I did.
我不得不说，在这场非常搞笑的戏里，我忍不住注意到斯通先生桌上的一个细节。这让我很分心，我想也许是因为个人原因吧。你有没有看到斯通先生的笔筒里有多少支削得整整齐齐、橡皮全新崭新的铅笔？是的，我看到了。
Is that because we have kids who are always doing their homework looking for pencils with full erasers that are like new pencils? That's my life. Yeah, I mean, in my house, everyone's searching for that one pencil that still has an eraser.
那是由于我们家里都有那种总是在做作业、到处找带完整橡皮的新铅笔的孩子吗？这就是我的生活。是的，我的意思是，在我家里，每个人都在寻找那支还带橡皮的铅笔。
You know, my mom gave my daughter this gift. It was part of like a Valentine's Day thing. My mom sends little boxes of presents and treats for the kids on the holidays. And she sent one for Valentine's Day this year. And it was a pencil that never needs to be sharpened. It's like an always ready pencil. I don't know where she got it.
你知道，我妈送了我女儿这个礼物。它是情人节礼物的一部分。我妈妈会在节假日给孩子们寄一小盒礼物和零食。她今年情人节寄了一份。那是一支永远不需要削的铅笔。就像是一支随时待命的铅笔。我不知道她从哪买的。
I've never heard of this. I know my mom goes to like craft fairs and art fairs and she finds these treasures and it's been wonderful but what I need now is also a pencil with an eraser that never disappears or pops off or can be chewed off. Right. So we've solved the one problem but now I'm looking for that other thing. So I was really drooling over this just cup of beautiful pencils with erasers. Pencils. I guess you know my life now, but I believe there's someone out there listening who can relate deeply. Yeah, I can relate. I'm right here. Okay. You're looking at her. Yeah. Back at Athlead, you know, Darryl is really impressed by the offices. And Pam says, yeah, Jim, you kind of undersold this, made it sound dinky.
我从来没听说过这个。我知道我妈妈会去那种手工艺品集市和艺术集市，她能找到这些宝贝，这真的很棒，但我现在需要的是一支橡皮永远不会消失、不会掉落或被咬掉的铅笔。好吧，我们解决了一个问题，但现在我又在找那个别的东西了。所以我真的对这杯插满漂亮带橡皮铅笔的笔筒垂涎三尺。铅笔。我想你现在了解我的生活了，但我相信外面的听众里有人能深深感同身受。是的，我能感同身受。我就在这儿呢。好吧。你在看着她呢。嗯。回到Athlead，你知道，Darryl对办公室印象非常深刻。Pam说：对啊，Jim，你之前有点低估这儿了，把它说得破破烂烂的。
Yeah. Jim says, hey, listen, it's only a startup. I haven't even gotten a paycheck yet. I mean, these things go down all the time." And that's when Daryl says, Well, I'd like to go down on with it. Yeah. We got a fan catch from Janelle W. in Northampton, Pennsylvania, who said the look between Pam and Jim seems to imply that Jenna and John are breaking. Was this a scripted line or did Craig actually have a blooper that made it into the final
没错。Jim说：嘿，听着，这只是一家初创公司。我甚至还没拿到工资呢。我的意思是，这种事经常发生。就在那时Darryl说：那我也想跟着它一起沉沦。是的。我们收到了来自宾夕法尼亚州北安普顿的珍妮尔·W（Janelle W.）的粉丝抓包，她说：Pam和Jim之间的眼神交流似乎暗示Jenna和John笑场了。这是剧本里的台词，还是Craig真的笑场了然后被剪进了成片
cut? Janelle, this was scripted. Yep. Craig just delivered it so well. So well. Mm-hmm. Back at Dunder Mifflin, Erin now has a big box of pins on her desk. She did it!
里？珍妮尔，这是剧本里写的。没错。Craig台词功底太好了。太好了。嗯哼。回到邓德米夫林，Erin的桌上现在有了一个装满大头针的大盒子。她成功了！
Yeah! The delivery went amazing! She's not going to unpack them then. Or should she unpack them? She's not sure if she should be a busybody or a lazybones. Her brain is ping-ponging with this question. Also, she's never had espresso before. So she's really amped up.
太棒了！这次配送太顺利了！她现在不打算把它们拆开。还是说她应该拆开它们？她不确定自己该当个爱管闲事的人还是个懒骨头。她的脑子里正为这个问题进行着乒乓球式的拉锯战。另外，她以前从未喝过浓缩咖啡。所以她现在超级亢奋。
Well, and fan catch from Maura L. in Long Island, New York, who said, I've been waiting the whole podcast to make this catch. Erin says she's never had an espresso before, but Michael makes her an espresso in Cafe Des Cans. Great catch, Maura. Well, you know, there was more to this pin delivery moment. There was a whole scene where the pins are delivered by a delivery guy named Mike.
对了，来自纽约长岛的莫拉·L（Maura L.）发来粉丝抓包说：我等了整个播客节目就是为了指出这个穿帮。Erin说她以前从未喝过浓缩咖啡，但Michael在《咖啡罐》（Cafe Des Cans）里给她做过浓缩咖啡。干得漂亮，莫拉。好吧，你知道的，这个大头针配送的时刻还有更多内容。本来有一整场戏，大头针是由一个叫Mike的快递员送来的。
It's really funny, and you can tell how caffeinated Aaron is. Let's hear it. Hello. I'm here to- Is this pens? Is this the delivery of pens? I don't know. I don't know what in the box is. Oh my gosh. It is the pens. It's the pens. Mike? Is it? It's the pens, Mike. We did it! Oh my gosh. Wait. I don't have any cash. How do I... What do I...
真的很好笑，而且你能看出Erin摄入了多少咖啡因。我们听听看。你好。我来——这是大头针吗？这是大头针的配送吗？我不知道。我不知道盒子里装的是什么。噢，天哪。真的是大头针。是大头针。Mike？是吗？是大头针，Mike。我们成功了！噢，天哪。等等。我没有现金。我怎么……我该怎么……
It's okay. It's all paid for. You motherf***** lifesaver. Get your sweet ass out of here before I do something crazy. Bye. She says, you motherf***ing lifesaver. Oh my gosh. This is crazy. She did it. She accepted a delivery of a box. There's a perfect storm happening for Erin, which is this delivery plus caffeine.
没关系。都已经付过钱了。你他妈的救命恩人。把你那迷人的屁股从这儿挪走，在我做出什么疯狂的事之前。拜拜。她说：你他妈的救命恩人。噢，天哪。这太疯狂了。她做到了。她成功签收了一箱快递。对于Erin来说，一场完美的风暴正在上演，那就是这次快递加上咖啡因。
Yeah. And it's just going to keep getting ratcheted up. I have to ask you a question, Angela. If you were you, not if you were Erin, but if you were you, would you put the pens away or just accept the delivery? Would you be a busybody or a lazybones? I'd be a busybody. I'd put them away. And then maybe you would come back and be like,
是的。而且情况只会越来越嗨。我得问你个问题，Angela。如果你是你自己，不是如果扮演Erin，而是如果你是你自己，你会把大头针收好，还是只管签收快递？你会当一个爱管闲事的人还是一个懒骨头？我会当个爱管闲事的人。我会把它们收好。然后也许你会回来然后说：
that's not where I intended them. And I would be like, oh, well, that's where the other ones were. I guess I'd have sass too. You'd be a sassy busybody. I would be a lazybones. Lazybones, just accept the delivery. That's what I was asked to do. That's what I'm going to do. And it's not because I don't like to go above and beyond, but I assume other people might have their system. And so I'm not going to get in the way of your system. I hear all of that. I just feel like pins. Like, I imagine
那不是我打算放它们的地方。我会想，哦，好吧，别的就在那儿。我想我也会顶嘴。你真是一个爱管闲事的八卦精。我会是个懒骨头。懒骨头，快把快递签收了吧。这就是我被要求做的事。这也是我要做的事。这倒不是因为我不喜欢精益求精，而是我猜别人可能有他们自己的一套系统。所以我就不打乱你们的系统了。我完全理解这些。我只是觉得……像……我想象
she has seen Pam restock the supply shelf. It's you though. Yeah. Oh, right. Sorry. It's me. It's not Erin. Okay. I would probably be a busybody. Hmm. Mm-hmm. What are you out there? Are you a busybody or a lazybones? I once had a coworker who called me Angela Two Cents. Why is that?
她看到帕姆重新整理了用品货架。不过是你。对。哦，对，抱歉。是我。不是艾琳。好吧。我大概会是个爱管闲事的人。嗯。嗯-hmm。你在外面是什么样的人？你是爱管闲事还是懒骨头？我以前有个同事叫我“两分钱安吉拉”。为什么这么叫？
I had to put my two cents in everywhere. How'd that go? You just had a sidebar comment? I guess I had a depension about how things were done. That doesn't even seem like you. Well, sit next to me in a cubicle all day. And then you're going to be Angela Two Cents? Then I turn into Angela Two Cents.
我到处都要发表高见。结果怎么样？你就随口插句话？我想我对事情该怎么做有一番长篇大论。这根本不像是你的作风。好吧，在隔间里跟我坐一整天。然后你就会变成“两分钱安吉拉”了？然后我就变成了“两分钱安吉拉”。
Hmm. This might be an interesting flavor to your mom detective's character. If I'm dropping everything and you're Angela Two Cents. Yeah. I'm liking this. It's growing. Well, listen, in the kitchen, the taste test is continuing.
嗯。这可能会给你的“妈妈侦探”角色增添一种有趣的色彩。如果我把一切都抛在脑后，而你是“两分钱安吉拉”。对。我挺喜欢这个的。它在发展。好吧，听着，在厨房里，品尝测试还在继续。
And energy is very high. This scene is going to end with Kevin lifting you, Angela. Yeah, like I'm a barbell. That was scripted, right? Yes. That he's lifting you up. It is. It was hilarious because I had to really make myself rigid, you know, like how you make
而且气氛非常高涨。这场戏的结尾是凯文把你抱起来，安吉拉。对，就像我是一个杠铃。那是剧本里写好的，对吧？是的。他把你抱起来。是的。太搞笑了，因为我必须让自己变得非常僵硬，你知道的，就像你把
your arms stiff at your side? Sure. So that he could do that many repetitions. Oh, uh-huh. You know what I mean? Were you jumping a little bit? Were you helping him a little? I was a little.
你的胳膊僵在身体两侧一样？没错。这样他才能做那么多次重复动作。哦，呃-hmm。你知道我的意思吗？你稍微跳了一下吗？你稍微帮了他一点吗？我稍微帮了一点。
Okay. Can you tell? No, but I know the tricks of the trade. Yeah. Well, because he had to do so many. And so to set me down all the way and get all, so I would just kind of spring down when, I think it was a real workout for Brian. Well, Angela, we got a fan question from Shalee D
好的。看得出来吗？看不出来，但我知道其中的门道。对。好吧，因为他必须做那么多下。为了让我完全放下并做好准备，我落地时会顺势弹一下。我想这对布莱恩来说真是一场锻炼。对了，安吉拉，我们收到了宾夕法尼亚州匹兹堡的沙利·D发来的一条关于这场戏的粉丝提问。
from Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania about this scene. Shalee wanted to know, was everyone actually having shots of different types of espresso? What were you actually drinking? Shaylee, no, we were not actually drinking espresso because I think we'd all get sick if we had to drink it all day like that. Thank goodness. We were drinking water. And if you got close to my cup, mine had iced tea in it.
沙利想知道，大家当时真的在喝不同种类的浓缩咖啡吗？你们当时到底在喝什么？沙利，不，我们当时并没有真的在喝浓缩咖啡，因为我想如果我们整天那样喝的话，大家都会生病的谢天谢地。我们喝的是水。如果你走近我的杯子，我的杯子里装的是冰茶。
Oh, could you kind of pick your beverage? Yeah. Or they would like color the water. Mm hmm. But it was mostly just water. We were all drinking water. I do remember having to pee. Yeah. Yeah. Well, in this scene, Nellie says her favorite so far is Viennese amaretto and her least favorite is Alpine Select. I looked these flavors up to see if they were real. Mm hmm. I mean, it's hard to say because I noticed that they do change flavors over the years. And this has been a long time ago now. It has. I did find an Italia Amaretti, so maybe that's the Viennese Amaretto that she likes, and I also found an Alpine Espresso
哦，你可以自己选饮料吗？对。或者他们会把水染成别的颜色。嗯哼。但大多时候只是水。我们当时都在喝水。我确实记得当时得上厕所。对。对。好吧，在这场戏里，内莉说她目前最喜欢的是维也纳杏仁味（Viennese amaretto），最不喜欢的是阿尔卑斯精选味（Alpine Select）。我查了这些口味，看看它们是不是真的。嗯哼。我是说，这很难说，因为我注意到这些年它们的口味确实在变。而且这已经是好久以前的事了。确实如此。我确实找到了一个意大利杏仁味（Italia Amaretti），所以也许这就是她喜欢的维也纳杏仁味，我还找到了一个阿尔卑斯浓缩咖啡
Martini flavor. Oh, I didn't stop there. Okay. I followed a link to Food and Wine because they had a ranking of Nespresso pod capsules and they said that the best overall original capsule is the Ristretto Italiano. Why is that? Well, here's a review. For a strong, bold shot of coffee that stands up to milk, the Ristretto Italiano is your best bet. The roast works well as a latte but is also delicious on its own. The roast is medium to dark with an intensity rating of 10. I don't think I'd like it.
马天尼口味。哦，我没止步于此。好吧。我点了一个链接，通往《美食与美酒》杂志，因为他们对 Nespresso 胶囊咖啡进行了排名，他们说整体最佳的原装胶囊是 Ristretto Italiano（意式浓缩咖啡）。为什么是这个？好吧，这里有一篇评论。对于经得起牛奶搭配的浓烈醇厚的咖啡，Ristretto Italiano 是您的最佳选择。这种烘焙口味做成拿铁很好喝，而且单喝也很美味。这种烘焙程度为中度到深度，浓郁度评分为 10。我想我不会喜欢它。
It sounds like it would get you going. Yeah, I don't want an intensity rating of 10 on my coffee. It doesn't say 10 out of what, 10 out of 100? Sure, 10 out of 10? No, thank you. That's my sidebar. You don't even drink coffee. I don't even drink coffee.
听起来它能让你瞬间精神焕发。对，我可不想在咖啡上有 10 分的浓郁度评分。它又没说是满分 100 分里的 10 分，还是满分 10 分里的 10 分？当然，10 分里的 10 分？不了，谢谢。这就是我的题外话。你甚至不喝咖啡。我甚至不喝咖啡。
This is a big thumbs down for you. Exactly. Well, there were more moments of everyone being over caffeinated and apparently caffeine Toby gets the courage to call the prison where he put a fella away. No. What? Yes. This is hilarious.
这对你来说绝对是个大差评。没错。好吧，还有更多大家摄入咖啡因过量的时刻，显然咖啡因让托比有了勇气给那个他曾把某个人送进去的监狱打电话。不会吧。什么？真的。太搞笑了。
I laughed so hard. I read it in the shooting draft. I immediately went to deleted scenes to see if it was there. It is. You have to hear it. Is this Waynesburg Prison? Yes. I'm calling actually for George Howard Scubb. You may know him as the Scranton Strangler. Well, just tell him it's someone who believes in second chances. Now, why would you forward a cryptic message like that?
我笑得太厉害了。我在拍摄初稿里读到了。我立刻去看被删减的片段，看看里面有没有。还真有。你们必须听听这个。这是韦恩斯堡监狱吗？是的。我其实是给乔治·霍华德·斯库布打的电话。你们可能知道他是斯克兰顿扼喉手。哦，只要告诉他这是一个相信有第二次机会的人打来的就好了。现在，你为什么要转发这么晦涩难懂的信息呢？
It is Toby Flenderson, juror number eight. The guy who held out for as long as he could and then gave to pressure and sent him away for the rest of his life. Yeah, I can hold. Yeah, I can hold. Imagine you're the person on the other line receiving that insane phone call. I know. Yeah, I can hold. Oh my gosh. That's not all. Overcaffeinated Creed and Meredith are gonna start a dance team. You gotta hear this. I just watched the show and I'm like, yeah, I do think I could dance. You know what I mean? We should start a dance team. Yes.
他是托比·弗伦德森，8号陪审员。那个尽可能坚持到底，最后却向压力屈服，把他送进监狱度过余生的人。对，我可以等。对，我可以等。想象一下你是电话那头听到那个疯狂电话的人。我懂。对，我可以等。哦天哪。这还不算完。咖啡因过量的克里德和梅雷迪思要组建一个舞蹈队。你们得听听这个。我刚看了节目，然后我就想，对，我觉得我确实能跳舞。你知道我的意思吗？我们应该组建一个舞蹈队。对。
Are you a poppin' locker or do you do floor work? Oh, I do floor work, all right. Ha! You're a firecracker. I love it. Are you a poppin' locker? Or you do floor work? While all this is going on, Dwight and Clark are continuing to be,
你是那种跳机械舞（poppin' locker）的还是跳地板动作的？哦，我擅长地板动作，没错。哈！你真是个开心果。我太喜欢了。你是那种跳机械舞的吗？还是你跳地板动作？正当这一切发生的时候，德怀特和克拉克继续保持着，
I guess, a bickering father and son. Yeah. Yeah, they're both trying to one-up each other on, like, who is the worst person in this duo. And then out of nowhere, Dwight accuses Clark of eating, quote, treats from the litter box. Yeah, it's a very long, very specific. Share. Yeah. And it's right around this time that Mr. Stone's son enters. Oh yeah. And this is when we're gonna find out
我猜，像一对爱拌嘴的父子。对。对。他们俩都在试图在谁是这两人中最糟糕的人这件事上胜过对方。然后莫名其妙地，德怀特指责克拉克吃了，引号，“猫砂盆里的零食”。是的，这是一段非常长、非常具体的分享。是的。就在这个时候，斯通先生的儿子进来了。哦，对。这就是我们要发现
that it's Sam Jr. who Dwight has been insulting ever since he arrived, is the real head of the business, that Father Stone has, I guess, maybe retired, he doesn't really work there, and Clark is gonna be like, hi, and just starts talking business to the son, luckily. Well, I've got a guest star alert. Mr. Stone's son was played by Will Greenberg.
小萨姆——也就是德怀特自从他到达以来一直在侮辱的那个人——才是斯通先生所拥有的生意的真正老板，斯通父亲大概已经退休了，他已经不在那里工作了，而克拉克则会说，嗨，然后幸运地开始和儿子谈生意。好吧，我有一个客串明星警报。斯通先生的儿子由威尔·格林伯格饰演。
He is a very successful comedy actor, and he can do impressions. Oh, yeah? Yes, according to his IMDb bio, he can quote, recite Shakespeare as Matthew McConaughey and sell Subway sandwiches as Denzel Washington. That is so specific. Yes, apparently he did both of those things
他是一位非常成功的喜剧演员，他会模仿。哦，是吗？是的，根据他的 IMDb 个人简介，他可以引号，“像马修·麦康纳一样背诵莎士比亚，像丹泽尔·华盛顿一样兜售赛百味三明治”。太具体了。是的，显然他在
in an audition for Saturday Night Live, and his Saturday Night Live audition tape went viral at one point, you can find it on YouTube. Okay. I also looked at all of his, you know, filmography and I found a crossover connection. Will Greenberg has been on The Grinder, that show with Rob Lowe that came out. I thought you were saying he was on the webs... what's it? It's an app. Oh, OnGrinder. OnGrinder, it's not a website, it's an app, and it's a hookup app. But there's also a TV show?
《周六夜现场》的试镜中做了这两件事，而且他的《周六夜现场》试镜带一度在网上疯传，你可以在 YouTube 上找到它。好的。我还看了他所有的，你知道的，影视作品，我发现了一个跨界联系。威尔·格林伯格出演过《律师V2.0》（The Grinder），就是罗伯·劳主演的那部播出的剧。我以为你刚才说他在网络……叫什么？那是个应用。哦，OnGrinder。OnGrinder，它不是个网站，是个应用，是个约会软件。但还有一部电视剧吗？
There was a TV, Jordan just laughed so hard I could hear her through the wall. What was it, Jordan, that tickled you? Was it Angela's description of the Grinder app? Yeah, it was the... Description of the hookup app. They're both in there laughing so hard at us. I also thought it was a website, but it's not. It's an app, like on your phone.
有一部电视剧，乔丹刚才笑得太厉害了，我都透过墙听到她笑了。是什么，乔丹，戳中了你的笑点？是安吉拉对 Grinder 应用的描述吗？对，就是那个……对约会软件的描述。他们俩都在里面笑话我们呢。我也以为那是个网站，但它不是。它是个应用，就像你手机上的那种。
Definitely not a website. Okay. But I thought it was for gay men. It is for... Oh, okay. Didn't we learn that on the podcast? We did. Someone explained it to us. Because they shut down, oh, the Olympics were happening and Grindr got fried.
绝对不是一个网站。好吧。但我以为那是给同性恋男生的。它是给……哦，好吧。我们在播客里不是学过吗？我们学过。有人给我们解释过。因为它们关闭了，哦，奥运会正在举行，然后 Grindr 崩溃了。
What happens when an app gets overrun with requests? I don't know. It shut down Grindr because there were so many people out and about, I guess, looking to meet someone. I think it should be called Pride. I think that's perfect. Anyway, I think that's when we learned about it a while back. That does not ring a bell for me.
当一个应用程序被请求淹没时会发生什么？我不知道。它关闭了 Grindr，因为有太多人在外面，我猜，想要结识新朋友。我觉得它应该叫“自豪”（Pride）。我觉得这太完美了。不管怎样，我想那是我们前段时间了解到的。我对那个没什么印象。
Oh. I feel like we had a guest came on and told us about Grindr. I don't remember. I can't remember. Anyway, clearly we didn't retain much of it. But well, this is not that this is a TV show. Okay, I just want to make it known. Will Greenberg was on a TV show called The Grindr. Was it about? It has literally nothing to do with hooking up. Okay, there you go. Okay, it's just a comedy TV show. It was starring Rob Lowe. Okay. And it was starring Mary Elizabeth Ellis.
哦。我觉得我们曾有一位嘉宾来过，跟我们讲过 Grindr。我不记得了。我记不起来了。不管怎样，显然我们没记住多少。不过，这不是那个，这是一个电视节目。好吧，我只是想让大家知道。威尔·格林伯格（Will Greenberg）曾出演过一部名为《律师 The Grinder》的电视剧。那是关于什么的？它和约会完全没有关系。好吧，就是这样。好吧，这只是一部喜剧电视剧。由罗伯·劳（Rob Lowe）主演。好吧。还有玛丽·伊丽莎白·埃利斯（Mary Elizabeth Ellis）主演。
It was so funny. I was obsessed with it. And I ran into the cast of The Grinder at like some party where we would, when we, in our other life, when we used to go to things. Yeah. I ran into them and I kind of stalked them.
太搞笑了。我当时迷上了它。我在某个聚会上碰到了《律师》剧组的人，当时我们，在我们的另一个生活里，我们过去常常去参加各种活动的时候。是的。我碰到了他们，然后我有点像跟踪他们一样跟着他们。
And I said, I want to be on your TV show. And I came on strong, like a little too strong. You? You? I did. And then I had my manager follow up and I eventually did get a role on the show. What?
我说，我想上你们的电视剧。我表现得很热情，有点太热情了。你？你？我是。然后我让我的经纪人跟进，我最终确实在剧里得到了一个角色。什么？
How did I not know about this? Oh, lady. And the thing was, was that my- You were on Grindr. I was on the Grindr. The Grindr. And my role on the show was of was that my- You were on Grindr. I was on The Grindr. The Grindr. And my role on the show was of this kind of like intense stalker woman. Oh.
我怎么会不知道这件事？哦，天哪。事情是这样的，我的——你上了 Grindr。我上了 The Grinder。The Grinder。我在剧里的角色是那种——你上了 Grindr。我上了 The Grinder。The Grinder。我在剧里的角色是一个有点像那种狂热的跟踪狂女性。哦。
Which I think maybe was because that's how I had- Of how you approached them. How I had come on so strong. But the crazy thing about me being on The Grindr was that it starred Rob Lowe, and it was my third project that I had done with Rob Lowe. I have this crazy connection to Rob Lowe. So the first movie I did in LA, I had three lines in this movie.
我想这可能是因为这就是我——你是怎么接近他们的。我是怎么表现得那么热情的。但关于我出演《律师》最疯狂的事情是，它由罗伯·劳主演，这是我与罗伯·劳合作的第三个项目。我和罗伯·劳有着这种疯狂的缘分。我在洛杉矶拍的第一部电影里，我只有三句台词。
The movie was starring Rob Lowe. I had no scenes with him. It was this indie film, and I'd actually been cast in a reading of the movie that we did for a bunch of investors. That's where you get interest. And I had the lead role opposite Rob Lowe in the readings. That's how I met him for the first time. But then when they got the money to do the movie,
这部电影由罗伯·劳主演。我和他没有对手戏。这是一部独立电影，我实际上是被选中参加我们为一群投资者举行的剧本围读会。这就是你吸引投资的地方。我在围读会上扮演与罗伯·劳演对手戏的主角。这就是我第一次见到他的原因。但是当他们筹集到资金开始拍电影时，
they recast me with like a name actress. But they did give me three lines and I got my side card. Okay. Okay. I saw Rob Lowe on set. He was really nice. He said, I'm sorry you didn't get to be the lead of the movie, but I hope you do well in the business. Okay. So then cut to after we finished doing The Office, I got cast in this TV show that shot in London. Yes. And Rob Lowe was one of the other leads of the TV show. We had no scenes together.
他们换了一个有名气的女演员来演我的角色。但他们确实给了我三句台词，我拿到了演员工会卡（SAG card）。好吧。好吧。我在片场看到了罗伯·劳。他人非常好。他说，很遗憾你没能演这部电影的主角，但我希望你在这一行发展顺利。好吧。后来，在我们拍完《办公室》之后，我接拍了这部在伦敦拍摄的电视剧。是的。罗伯·劳是这部电视剧的主演之一。我们没有对手戏。
Oh. Didn't see him a single day on set. OK. It was not until The Grinder. Oh. Third project together. Technically fourth, if you count the reading. Did you have a scene together? We had a scene.
哦。在片场一天都没见到他。好的。直到《律师》。哦。第三次合作。严格来说如果是算围读的话是第四次。你们有对手戏吗？我们有一场对手戏。
I was his crazy ex-stalker fiance. Oh my gosh. It was set in the past, and we all had, like, funny past hairdos and stuff. I was only on set for one day. It was the grinder. Okay. Not the app. How did I miss this information? I don't know. I wonder what you were up to when I was on the grinder.
我是他疯狂的前未婚妻兼跟踪狂。哦天哪。那是设定在过去的场景，我们所有人都有那种好笑的过去的发型之类的。我在片场只呆了一天。那是《律师》。好吧。不是那个应用程序。我怎么会错过这个信息？我不知道。我很好奇当我拍《律师》的时候你在干什么。
I don't know. I have a picture. I'll give it to you for stories lady. Well, I have a Rob Lowe story. What's your Rob Lowe story? I played him in ping pong for Clayton Kershaw does a charity called Ping Pong for Purpose. I've gone to that. And Josh and I played against Rob Lowe and another Dodger baseball player. And we only lost by like two points. They won? They won, but only by two. It was like back and forth. Yeah.
我不知道。我有一张照片。我会发给你作为“故事”素材，女士。好吧，我有一个关于罗伯·劳的故事。你的罗伯·劳故事是什么？我和他一起打过乒乓球。克莱顿·克肖（Clayton Kershaw）举办了一个名为“乒乓球为目标（Ping Pong for Purpose）”的慈善活动。我去过那个活动。乔什和我对阵罗伯·劳和另一个道奇队的棒球运动员。我们只输了两分左右。他们赢了？他们赢了，但只赢了两分。就像你来我往那样。是的。
So I have played ping pong with Rob Lowe. But yeah, he was very nice. He had good sportsmanship. He had good sportsmanship. That's such a mom thing to say. Right. Well, I loved that nice young man with the good sportsmanship. You know what?
所以我跟罗伯·劳打过乒乓球。但是是的，他人非常好。他很有体育精神。他很有体育精神。这真是一句妈妈才会说的话。对。好吧，我很喜欢那个有良好体育精神的年轻好小伙。你知道吗？
They were a classy team. They had good sportsmanship. You know what? They were a classy team. They had good sportsmanship. Clean language. Good, clean fun on the field today. Well, that was a tangent. It was. Well, thank you for going down memory lane with me. The podcast is kind of fun, and because we
他们是一个有档次的团队。他们很有体育精神。你知道吗？他们是一个有档次的团队。他们很有体育精神。语言干净。今天在球场上玩得开心又健康。好吧，那是一个题外话。确实是。好吧，谢谢你陪我一起回忆过去。这个播客挺有意思的，因为我们
are kind of solidifying for all time some of these stories that I mean I could imagine maybe we would forget them when we got older. So when we're old we can re-listen to our podcast and remember stuff? We can remember everything about every episode we shot of The Office and some extras. Okay. So before the podcast is over if there's anything you want to commit to memory make a list and we'll go through it on the pod. I feel like that's another podcast. Things we don't want to forget. With Jenna and Angela.
正在为永远巩固其中一些故事，我的意思是，我可以想象也许我们老了以后会忘记它们。所以当我们老了的时候，我们可以重新收听我们的播客并记起一些事情？我们可以记住我们拍摄的每一集《办公室》以及一些花絮的所有事情。好的。所以在播客结束之前，如果有什么你想牢记在心的东西，列个清单，我们会在播客里过一遍。我觉得那是另一个播客。我们不想忘记的事情。作者：珍娜和安吉拉。
Yeah, exactly. All right. Well, you know what Sam Jr. thinks? Clark needs a new suit, a new nice expensive Italian silk suit. Dwight is like, nope, no he doesn't. But yeah, Sam Jr. will insist. Clark definitely wants the suit. If he wants a tie, it's gonna be $9. Check out the sign in the background.
对，没错。好吧，你知道小萨姆（Sam Jr.）怎么想吗？克拉克需要一套新西装，一套漂亮的昂贵意大利真丝西装。德怀特觉得：不，他不需要。但是，小萨姆会坚持。克拉克绝对想要这套西装。如果他想要一条领带，只要9美元。看看背景里的牌子。
I didn't see that, that's great. You can get five for $35. The guys make the sale and they both get a suit. So at the end of the day, Clark came through. He sure did. It was because of Clark they made the sale, frankly. Yeah. The sale went well, but Darryl's interview is not going well.
我没看到那个，太棒了。你花35美元可以买五条。这几个家伙做成了这笔生意，他们俩都得到了一套西装。所以归根结底，克拉克成功了。他确实做到了。坦白说，多亏了克拉克他们才做成了这笔生意。是的。生意进展顺利，但达里尔的面试进展得不太顺利。
It's not. And you know what? Jim tries to help him out. He says, I find it helpful to picture everyone naked. I thought that was so awkward. It was so awkward. To stay in a room of people. You know, we've seen this before with Darryl in interviews. He kind of chokes. He's not great.
确实不顺利。你知道吗？吉姆试图帮他一把。他说，我发现把每个人都想象成赤身裸体很有帮助。我觉得这太尴尬了。太尴尬了。身处一屋子人当中。你知道，我们以前在面试中也见过达里尔这样。他有点语塞。他不太擅长这个。
He freezes. He does. And he's our best employee. He's one of those people who just doesn't interview well. He would really benefit from some interview coaching. But everyone's really encouraging. Darryl says, listen, I shouldn't even be here. I just manage a warehouse. And everyone's like, what are you talking about? Like, they name all their other jobs they had before starting this company. So Darrell sits back down and he kind of composes himself. He hands out this very impressive booklet he's put together on his thoughts for the company. I have something to share. Yes? While Daryl's interview is going on, there is a wonderful scene of Pam waiting for Daryl at front reception. When I reread the shooting draft, it made me laugh out loud. It is not
他僵住了。确实如此。他是我们最好的员工。他是那种很不擅长面试的人。如果能接受一些面试辅导，他会受益匪浅的。但每个人都在极力鼓励他。达里尔说，听着，我甚至不应该来这里。我只是管理一个仓库。然后大家都说，你在说什么呢？就像，他们说出了他们在开始这家公司之前做过的所有其他工作。于是达里尔重新坐下，他稍微镇定了一下。他拿出了这本非常厚重的册子，上面写满了对公司的想法。我有件事要分享。什么事？在达里尔面试进行的同时，有一个精彩的场景，帕姆在前台接待处等达里尔。当我重新阅读拍摄剧本时，我忍不住笑出声来。它没有
on the DVDs, but I want to read it to you. Oh, I remember shooting this. Go ahead. Interior Philadelphia office reception area. Pam sits on the leather sofa in the front, a little bored as she waits for the interview to finish. She leaps through magazines on a table. ESPN magazine, Golf Digest, Baseball Digest, Sporting News, none of which she has any interest in. She takes out her iPhone, tries to surf the web, the receptionist walks over from the outer office. This made me laugh. The receptionist says to Pam, our wireless password is athlete, all lower case
出现在DVD上，但我读给你听。哦，我还记得拍摄这一幕的情景。请念吧。内景。费城办公室接待区。帕姆坐在前面的皮沙发上，等面试结束时有点无聊。她翻看着桌上的杂志。《ESPN杂志》、《高尔夫文摘》、《棒球文摘》、《体育新闻》，这些她全都不感兴趣。她拿出iPhone，试图上网，接待员从外间的办公室走了过来。这把我逗笑了。接待员对帕姆说，我们的无线网络密码是athlete，全部小写
except the A's, and then the L is a one, and the H is a B, and the D is three ampersands. Pam tries and then gives up, says, I'm okay, thanks. Pam tries and then gives up, says, I'm okay, thanks. One of the things, Jenna, that when we started the podcast, when our offices were at Earwulf, every single time we went in, we'd have to log on to get internet. Oh, I hated that system. And the password was so long and ridiculous. And when I read that, it just made me think of that. You know, you mentioned the receptionist.
除了A是大写，然后L是一个数字1，H是一个字母B，D是三个“与”符号（&）。帕姆试了一下然后放弃了，说，我挺好的，谢谢。帕姆试了一下然后放弃了，说，我挺好的，谢谢。珍娜，有一件事，当我们刚开始做播客时，我们的办公室在Earwulf，每次我们进去，我们都必须登录才能上网。哦，我讨厌那个系统。那个密码太长太荒谬了。当我读到那段时，就让我想起了那个。你知道的，你刚才提到了接待员。
We got a fan question from Liv H in Sweden who said, I feel like if Athlead is a startup company and Jim doesn't even have a paycheck, how do they afford this receptionist? Like what does he do? Do they really need one? It felt like a weird priority. You know, I wonder if this person is an intern. Like, a lot of startups will get, like, unpaid interns, and then they get, I don't know, like, credit for school or something.
我们收到了来自瑞典的粉丝 Liv H 的提问，她说：“我觉得如果 Athlead 是一家初创公司，而 Jim 甚至没有薪水，他们怎么请得起这个前台？他到底是干什么的？他们真的需要前台吗？这感觉像是一个奇怪的优先事项。你知道，我在想这个人是不是实习生。很多初创公司会招无薪实习生，然后他们不知道，能拿到学校的学分什么的。”
Yeah, that made me wonder, because it's a good point. The receptionist was played by René Goubet. He's a comedian and he is currently working as a writer and co-executive producer of The Bear. And before that, he was a co-executive producer of Justin Spitzer's show Superstore. Well, Darrell's presentation has gone really well. He's really turned things around. Everyone agrees. And sort of in the moment he grabs a basketball that was there and- A signed basketball. Why would you shoot that in the first place?
是的，这让我很好奇，因为这是一个很好的观点。前台是由 René Goubet 扮演的。他是一名喜剧演员，目前担任《熊家餐馆》的编剧和联合执行制片人。在此之前，他是贾斯汀·斯派策的节目《超级超市》的联合执行制片人。好吧，Daryl 的演讲进行得非常顺利。他真的扭转了局面。大家都很赞同。然后他顺手抓起旁边的一个篮球——一个签过名的篮球。你一开始为什么要投那个？
I don't know. Go on. I know and he tosses it to a basketball hoop, which is oddly placed near a light and a fish tank. He misses, it knocks the light into the fish tank and electrocutes all the fish. We got a fan mail flurry. I bet. People want to know how did we do this? Did we have a safety meeting? That spark looked so real. Um, how many takes was it to get the ball to hit the basket and the wall and the light and the tank? Were the fish fake?
我不知道。继续。我知道，然后他把球投向了一个篮球框，这个篮框奇怪地放在一盏灯和一个鱼缸附近。他没投中，球把灯撞进了鱼缸里，电死了所有的鱼。我们收到了雪片般的粉丝信。我敢打赌。人们想知道我们是怎么做到的？我们开过安全会议吗？那个火花看起来太真实了。嗯，为了让球击中篮筐、墙壁、灯和鱼缸，拍了多少条？鱼是假的吗？
Tell us everything about this scene. Well, luckily Matt Stone had a lot to say about this scene. Let's have a listen. Let's see, the moment where Daryl accidentally electrocutes the fish was a fun gag. We had rigged the lamp to fall into the fish tank and to pulsate, you know, to sell the electric shock. The floating dead fish really sold that moment. We had to work backwards on this bit. Phil Shea found the dead fish that we ultimately used.
给我们讲讲关于这个场景的一切吧。好吧，幸运的是 Matt Stone 对这个场景有很多话要说。我们来听听。让我们看看，Daryl 意外电死鱼的那一刻是个有趣的笑话。我们给灯做了索具，让它掉进鱼缸里并闪烁，你知道的，为了呈现触电的效果。漂浮的死鱼真的很到位。我们不得不倒着拍摄这个片段。Phil Shea 找到了我们最终使用的死鱼。
You know, some were floating at the top of the tank and some were tied to monofilament. So they would float in the middle of the tank. The challenge that we had was to find the live fish to match the dead ones that Phil had found, which we ultimately did, so we could sell that there were live fish in the tank in other shots before
你知道，有些漂浮在鱼缸顶部，有些则系在单丝钓鱼线上。所以它们会漂浮在鱼缸中间。我们面临的挑战是找到活鱼来与 Phil 找到的死鱼相匹配，我们最终做到了，这样我们就可以在之前的镜头中展示鱼缸里有活鱼。
Darrell throws the basketball. And I believe that Craig made that shot on the first take, but we did ultimately reset and did it a second time. I'm sorry. Yeah. You can buy dead fish. Well, I had that question. Uh-huh. I followed up with Matt. I said, do you mean real dead fish? Well, I had that question.
Daryl 投掷篮球。我相信 Craig 第一条就投进了，但我们最终还是重置并拍了第二条。我很抱歉。是的。你可以买到死鱼。好吧，我有这个疑问。嗯哼。我跟进问了 Matt。我说，你是说真正的死鱼吗？好吧，我有这个疑问。
I followed up with Matt. I said, do you mean real dead fish or fake dead fish? Here's what Matt had to say. OK. The fish that Phil Shea found were real dead fish, and they were sent to us frozen and packed. By about halfway through the shoot, most of the fish had thawed out and had started to smell.
我跟进问了 Matt。我说，你是说真正的死鱼还是假的死鱼？Matt 是这么说的。好的。Phil Shea 找到的鱼是真正的死鱼，它们被冷冻并打包发给我们。大约在拍摄过半时，大部分鱼都已经解冻并开始散发出气味。
So it wasn't the most pleasant odor on set. That is so gross. Yeah, I mean, were these dead fish that you could eat? Are these fish edible? I don't know what kind of fish they were. Like your mallard story. We may never know. We're left with questions. Steve Burgess added that the light that fell into the tank was rigged so it could only fall in the tank. And we added a safety to the light, kind of like the GFI in your kitchen, so that no one would get hurt when it sparked.
所以片场的气味并不是最令人愉快的。太恶心了。是的，我是说，这些死鱼是你可以吃的吗？这些鱼可以吃吗？我不知道它们是什么种类的鱼。就像你的绿头鸭故事一样。我们可能永远不会知道。我们留下了疑问。Steve Burgess 补充说，掉进鱼缸里的灯经过了索具处理，使其只能掉进鱼缸里。我们在灯上加了一个安全装置，有点像你厨房里的 GFI（漏电保护器），这样当它产生火花时就不会有人受伤。
It was a grounded safety thing. Probably not the technical term. Grounded safety thing. Yeah. I loved all of that behind the scenes detail about that one stunt. That's amazing what all went into that. Well, Darryl now joins Pam at front reception. He's really down in the dumps because he just electrocuted everyone's fish. Why are you laughing?
这是一个接地安全装置。可能不是专业术语。接地安全装置。是的。我很喜欢关于那个特技的所有幕后细节。这太神奇了，里面有这么多门道。好吧，Daryl 现在来到前台加入 Pam 的行列。他情绪非常低落，因为他刚刚电死了大家的鱼。你笑什么？
Down in the dumps? Is that a bad expression? I haven't known when to tell you. What's on me? Is something on me? Some cheese. Oh, I have a cheese on my boob. I have cheese.
情绪低落？这是一个不好的表达吗？我一直不知道该什么时候告诉你。我身上有什么？我身上有什么东西吗？一些奶酪。哦，我胸部上有块奶酪。我有奶酪。
It's actually a cracker. It's a cracker. I should have maybe just. I ate it off my boob. You know what? I remember you doing that early on the podcast. I remember you doing it. You got a little thing.
其实是一块饼干。是一块饼干。我本该直接……我把它从我胸上吃掉了。你知道吗？我记得你在播客早期做过这件事。我记得你做过。你身上沾了点东西。
Oh, it was me. It was you, it wasn't me. Sorry. I don't have any problem with eating stuff that's fallen off. Off your clothing. I know. That's fallen onto you. I don't have a problem with that.
哦，是我。是你，不是我。抱歉。对于吃掉掉落的东西，我没有任何意见。掉在你的衣服上。我知道。掉到你身上的东西。我对这个没有意见。
I had a little snack, guys, and I guess. My dad used to say, well, you have a hitchhiker. You had a hitchhiker, lady. I had a hitchhiker. All right. Anyway, as I was saying, Darrell is down in the dumps, and Pam is trying to reassure him.
我吃了个小零食，伙计们，我想。我爸爸以前常说，嗯，你有个搭便车的。你有个搭便车的人，女士。我有个搭便车的人。好吧，不管怎样，正如我所说，Daryl 情绪低落，而 Pam 正试图安慰他。
She's like, you know what, at the end of the day, you have a great job where people love you. Yeah. They start really bonding. He's like, you know what, I don't even think I want to live in Philly. And Pam's like, yeah, it's not in New York or London or Paris.
她说，你知道吗，归根结底，你有一份人们都很喜欢你的好工作。是的。他们开始真正建立感情。他说，你知道吗，我甚至不想住在费城了。Pam 就说，是的，它又不是纽约、伦敦或巴黎。
Who needs Philly? Jim comes out and says, guess what? You got the job. Daryl loves Philly. All of a sudden, Daryl's super into Philly. Two, one, five, or die. Yeah. Pam has a talking head.
谁需要费城？Jim 出来说，你猜怎么着？你被录用了。Daryl 太喜欢费城了。突然之间，Daryl 对费城超级感兴趣。215 区或死亡。是的。Pam 有一个访谈镜头。
She says she's not upset. She's happy for Daryl, but she's a little disappointed they'll be losing him. Yeah. Pam has a talking head. She says she's not upset. She's happy for Darryl. But she's a little disappointed they'll be losing him. Yeah. Back at Dunder Mifflin, Erin decided to be a busybody. She goes to unbox the pens, and everyone gives her grief about it. She gets all flustered. She puts the pens back in the box. She is not gunning for Pam's job, okay? But it's also, it's getting sweaty over an accounting. It's getting real sweaty. Here is how the scene was described in the shooting draft. Interior office accounting area.
她说她并不难过。她为 Daryl 感到高兴，但她有点失望他们会失去他。是的。Pam 有一个访谈镜头。她说她并不难过。她为 Daryl 感到高兴。但她有点失望他们会失去他。是的。回到邓德米夫林，Erin 决定管闲事。她去拆开笔的包装，每个人都因此抱怨她。她慌乱了。她把笔放回盒子里。她并不是在图谋 Pam 的工作，好吧？但这也是，会计部那边压力山大。压力真的太大了。以下是拍摄剧本中对该场景的描述。室内办公室会计区。
Kevin is fidgety at his desk. He has his suit jacket off and he has gigantic armpit sweat stains as well as sweat beads on his forehead. We can hear an off-screen banging. Camera pans left to reveal Oscar, who also has huge armpit sweat stains. Camera now pans right to reveal Angela leaning over towards the window,
Kevin 在办公桌前坐立不安。他脱掉了西装外套，腋下有巨大的汗渍，额头上也有汗珠。我们可以听到画外音传来的敲击声。镜头向左摇，露出 Oscar，他也有巨大的腋下汗渍。镜头现在向右摇，露出 Angela 向着窗户倾斜，
and we realize the banging has been her smacking the window to try to open it. She turns towards them, and we see that she, too, has enormous armpit stains. Everything to do with the armpit stains is in all caps and bold. They were very serious. They wanted us to have giant armpit stains. We got some fan mail about this scene. Angela, people loved it. Allie P from Idaho said, I love how high pitched everyone's voice gets, the deeper you get into the episode and the more caffeine they've had.
我们意识到敲击声是她为了打开窗户而在拍打窗户。她转向他们，我们发现她身上也有巨大的腋下汗渍。所有关于腋下汗渍的描述都是全大写加粗的。他们非常严肃。他们希望我们有巨大的腋下汗渍。我们收到了一些关于这个场景的粉丝信。Angela，大家都很喜欢。来自爱达荷州的 Allie P 说，我喜欢随着你深入观看这一集以及他们喝了更多咖啡，每个人的声音变得有多尖锐。
And Levi D from Michigan said, Angela, how many takes did it take for you to get through that line? I do not understand the point of windows. The messy hair and sweaty pit reveal was so funny. Well, Levi, the first thing is when they wrote this scene, we did it at the table read, none of us realized or remembered that that window is covered by blinds. So we sort of had to figure that out on the day that I would tuck in behind the blinds. And it was great because it naturally messed up my hair.
来自密歇根州的 Levi D 说，Angela，你拍了多少条才顺利说完那句台词？我不明白窗户的意义何在。凌乱的头发和汗湿的腋窝的特写太搞笑了。嗯，Levi，首先是当他们写这个场景时，我们在剧本围读时，我们谁也没有意识到或记起那扇窗户是被百叶窗挡住的。所以我们只能在拍摄当天临时想办法让我藏在百叶窗后面。这太棒了，因为它自然地弄乱了我的头发。
Oh yeah, we should tell people that's a completely fakie window. Yeah, that window goes nowhere. I actually loved that the blinds were there because it gave me a bit of business to have to like wrestle with as I come out from trying to open the window. And we had so much fun in that scene.
哦，是的，我们应该告诉大家那是完全假的窗户。是的，那扇窗户通往任何地方。我其实很喜欢那些百叶窗，因为它给我提供了一些互动动作，当我试图开窗出来时，我必须和它“搏斗”。我们在那个场景中玩得太开心了。
So much fun. I think we only got to do a few takes of it, if I remember correctly, but we were having the best time. Well, Angela, Matt Zonehn talked about all that sweat and the caffeine corner storyline. Let's have a listen. So, Dan Grainy was the writer of this episode.
太开心了。如果我没记错的话，我想我们只拍了几条，但我们度过了最美好的时光。嗯，Angela，Matt Zohn 谈到了所有的汗水和咖啡角的故事情节。我们来听听。所以，Dan Grainy 是这一集的编剧。
We had had several conversations on how to best sell the escalation of the caffeine frenzy of the people in the office. You know, it started with the cast slowly getting amped up. You know, they're all trying out the different espressos. They decide that they're all going to have this challenge and try each flavor. I think that also leads to Kevin picking up Angela. I think that moment had us laughing.
我们曾多次讨论如何最好地展现办公室里人们咖啡狂热的升级。你知道，它始于演员们慢慢变得亢奋。你知道，他们都在尝试不同的意式浓缩咖啡。他们决定所有人都要接受这个挑战，尝试每一种口味。我认为这也导致了 Kevin 把 Angela 抱起来。我认为那一刻让我们大笑。
You know, there's also the moment of Stanley working away. He's very positive and upbeat and happy. You know, Kevin is rolling around on his chair in the office. Then things start to go a little wrong. That's when everybody starts to get the sweats. We had several different versions of the amount of sweat everybody had. You know, we started light and then went heavier. You know, and I think it was obvious that
你知道的，还有斯坦利努力工作的时刻。他非常积极、乐观和高兴。你知道的，凯文在办公室的椅子上转来转去。然后事情开始有点不对劲了。也就是从那时起，每个人都开始流汗了。对于每个人流汗的程度，我们有好几个不同的版本。你知道的，我们从轻微开始，然后逐渐增加。你知道的，而且我认为很明显
the heavier, sweaty people made everybody laugh more. So that's ultimately what we went for. Do you remember that at all, Angela? Do you remember them like spritzing you with sweat and then they were like more. Oh yeah. Oh yeah. Yeah they also purposely had me in a long sleeve shirt so I could show more sweat because normally I wear like a little blouse. Sure. And hair and makeup were standing just right off camera and they had the spray bottles and they would come in and squirt us like to get us more damp. What'd you do at work today? I got squirted in my armpits with water bottles.
汗流得越多的人越能逗大家笑。所以这才是我们最终的选择。安吉拉，你还记得这事吗？你还记得他们往你身上喷汗，然后他们说再多一点吗？哦，是的。哦，是的。是的，他们还特意让我穿一件长袖衬衫，这样我能表现出更多的汗水，因为平时我穿的都是那种小衬衫。当然。发型和化妆师就站在镜头外，他们拿着喷雾瓶过来给我们喷水，让我们更湿润。你今天在工作时做什么了？我的咯吱窝被水瓶喷了水。
And then I watched dead fish get thawed out. What is your job? Well now that they have all this energy, Oscar suggests that they move the copier into the annex like they've always wanted to. Yes, I loved it when Kevin was like, goodbye noise. Isn't there already a copier in the annex? There is, but they just needed a project lady. I guess so.
然后我看着死鱼被解冻。你的工作是什么？好吧，既然他们现在精力充沛，奥斯卡建议他们像一直以来想的那样，把复印机搬到附楼去。是的，我太喜欢凯文说“再见，噪音”的时候了。附楼里不是已经有一台复印机了吗？有的，但他们只是需要一个项目，女士。我想是的。
Well, when they start moving this copier, it rips up the carpet and it reveals beautiful hardwood floors, which Oscar knew were there all along. Yeah, Oscar's so happy about it. Meredith yells for them to rip up all the carpet. Yeah. We need to see all the hardwood floors. Angela, I have to ask, what do you
好吧，当他们开始搬这台复印机时，地毯被扯破了，露出了漂亮的硬木地板，奥斯卡其实一直都知道那里有。是的，奥斯卡对此高兴极了。梅雷迪思大喊让他们把所有的地毯都扯掉。是的。我们需要看到所有的硬木地板。安吉拉，我不得不问，你对
remember about this scene? You aren't really physically ripping up the carpet, but what do you remember from shooting this? I mean, everybody had a really good time. I don't know what it is. When you're given permission to, like, rip something or pull something apart, I think everybody is like, I'm here for it. Get out some of your aggressions.
这个场景有什么记忆？你们并不是真的在物理上扯地毯，但拍摄时你还记得什么？我的意思是，大家玩得真的很开心。我不知道为什么。当你被允许去，比如说，撕碎某物或把某物扯开时，我想每个人都会觉得，我太喜欢了。释放一些压力。
I just like that everything was giving Angela a headache. Yes. Well, she gets her headaches, you know. She does. We got a fan question from Jessica N. in Rochester, New York, who said, how did they get the wooden flooring underneath the carpet in the office? Did they set it on top of real gray carpet and then add another layer of carpet?
我只是觉得一切都让安吉拉头疼。是的。好吧，她总会有头疼的时候，你知道的。确实如此。我们收到了来自纽约州罗切斯特市的杰西卡·N的粉丝提问，她说：“办公室地毯下面的木地板是怎么弄的？它们是铺在真正的灰色地毯上面，然后又加了一层地毯吗？”
Whatever they did, I'm sure it was a lot of work. Steve Burgess said, it was a lot of work, I bet. That basically we picked the areas where we would see the flooring, we ripped up the carpet, we put down the flooring, we put carpet back on top of it, we ripped up the carpet. But in the end, we had to pull up all the carpet and replace it for the next episode. Matt said they had a carpet installation team standing by to fix it as soon as we wrapped, and Steve Burgess reminded me that
不管他们做了什么，我敢说那肯定有很多工作。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说：“那确实有很多工作，我敢说。基本上就是我们挑选了能看到地板的区域，扯掉地毯，铺上地板，再把地毯铺回上面，然后再扯掉地毯。但最后，我们不得不把所有的地毯都拉起来，为下一集更换地毯。”马特说他们有一支地毯安装团队随时待命，在我们收工后立即修复它，史蒂夫·伯吉斯提醒我
this is not the first time we've had to replace a bunch of carpet. He said, remember when Michael proposed to Holly and it set off all the sprinklers, he said we had to replace all of the carpet after that episode as well. And one square when Kevin spills the chili. Oh yeah, that's true. I think we had to replace the carpet in Michael's office when Packer put the poop in there too. Oh right. Anyway. We were busy.
这已经不是我们第一次不得不更换一大堆地毯了。他说，还记得迈克尔向霍莉求婚时触发了所有的喷淋装置吗，他说那一集之后我们也必须更换所有的地毯。还有凯文洒了辣椒的那一次。哦，对，那是真的。我想当帕克把便便放进迈克尔的办公室时，我们也得换地毯。哦，对了。不管怎样。我们当时很忙。
We kept the carpet people busy. We did. Well, after they rip up all the carpet, everyone's going to try to leave simultaneously. And it doesn't go well in the parking lot. This scene really cracks me up. I went to the shooting draft, and this is how it was described. Exterior parking lot, moments later. From the upstairs window, we see people in their cars caught in a huge traffic snarl.
我们让地毯工人忙个不停。我们确实如此。好吧，在他们扯掉所有的地毯后，每个人都试图同时离开。而且停车场的情况很不妙。这个场景真的让我笑喷了。我查了拍摄剧本，它是这样描述的：外景，停车场，片刻之后。从楼上的窗户，我们看到人们在车里陷入了巨大的交通拥堵中。
It's a cacophony of honking horns with a few people leaning out their windows and yelling, others gunning it then slamming on their brakes. Someone dangerously tries to weave between cars, etc. So there was no dialogue scripted for us. Everything that you see in the parking lot are heard. That was all improvised in the moment. Oh, wow Mm-hmm. Very good. Yeah, and Obviously all the car movements were completely planned. Everyone knew exactly where they were going in their car So there was no actual real fender bender so
喇叭声此起彼伏，几个人把身子探出车窗大喊大叫，其他人则猛踩油门然后急刹车。有人危险地在车流中穿行，等等。所以我们没有任何台词剧本。你在停车场看到或听到的一切。那全都是当时即兴发挥的。哦，哇。嗯哼。非常棒。是的，而且显然所有的汽车移动都是完全计划好的。每个人都知道他们的车要去哪里，所以并没有真的发生什么剐蹭，所以
Movement choreographed lines improvised exactly. Well, Daryl and Pam are back in the car. They're heading back to Scranton. Daryl is so pumped. So excited. He starts singing. Pam reluctantly joins in. She's having a lot of feelings. Yeah, she's in her head.
动作是编排好的，台词是即兴发挥的，确实如此。好吧，达里尔和帕姆又回到了车里。他们正返回斯克兰顿。达里尔斗志昂扬。兴奋极了。他开始唱歌。帕姆勉强加入。她心里有很多情绪。是的，她陷在自己的思绪里。
Mm-hmm. Matt sent us in an audio clip about this scene. Here's what he had to say. I know that Craig and Jenna had a lot of fun in the car, on the drive, back to Philly. Though it was ultimately an emotional scene, there were takes of them singing the song where they both broke up and had a really good time with each other and the song. I bet you guys had a blast. We did. It was rare for Pam and Darryl to be teamed up in a storyline. Just how I had had so much fun finally being teamed up with Kate for Lice.
嗯哼。马特给我们发来了一段关于这个场景的音频剪辑。他是这么说的：我知道克雷格和詹娜在车里、在回费城的路上玩得很开心。尽管这最终是一个感性的场景，但他们唱这首歌的某些镜头里，两人都笑场了，并且和对方以及这首歌玩得很开心。我敢打赌你们当时乐翻了。我们确实如此。帕姆和达里尔在一条故事线中搭档是很罕见的。就像我终于能和凯特搭档拍《长虱子》时玩得那么开心一样。
I was so excited to be teamed up with Craig for this episode. Craig is a lot of fun and I had to pretend to be in my head but then you know if Craig sings you want to sing he's so infectious that way and I love that Matt said that because I just did a little project and Craig was in it mm-hmm I just filmed an AT&T commercial and it had a bunch of office people in it. It was me, Rain, Craig, Brian, Kate, and Creed. We got to shoot for two days together. And you said you and Craig got to do some fun stuff. Craig and I got to do a scene together,
我很高兴能在这一集里和克雷格搭档。克雷格非常有趣，我必须假装陷在自己的思绪里，但你知道的，如果克雷格唱歌，你就会想跟着唱，他就是有那种感染力，我喜欢马特说的那样，因为我刚刚做了一个小项目，克雷格也在里面。嗯哼。我刚拍了一个AT&T的广告，里面有一群办公室的人。有我、雷恩、克雷格、布莱恩、凯特和克里德。我们一起拍了两天。你说你和克雷格做了一些有趣的事情。我和克雷格一起拍了一个场景，
and we got to improvise, and we had so much fun. The director actually came over and was like, oh, my gosh, you guys have a lot of chemistry. You guys are good together. And we were like, yes, we are. I just, I loved seeing this scene and I loved getting to work with Craig again to really work with all those guys again. It was crazy. And it just this commercial, it just came out like a few days ago. How fun lady. What a fun reunion. I know. And Angie, I know you had a thing that...
我们进行了即兴表演，我们玩得太开心了。导演甚至走过来，天哪，你们俩太有化学反应了。你们在一起合作得真好。然后我们就想，是的，我们确实很好。我就是，我很喜欢看到这个场景，并且我很高兴能再次和克雷格合作，能再次和所有这些家伙合作。太疯狂了。而且这个广告，就在几天前刚刚上映。多有趣的女士啊。多有趣的重逢啊。我知道。安吉拉，我知道你有一件事...
I did. I can't talk about it yet. I can't talk about it yet, but I had my own little mini office reunion shoot, too, and it was the same thing. I was so delighted to be back with my castmates from the office. We instantly fell right back in sync. It was so fun. That's how we were. Everybody was so good, and I have to say, it made me, like...
我有。我还不能谈。我还不能谈，但我也有我自己的办公室迷你重逢拍摄，而且是一样的。能和我在办公室的演员搭档重聚，我太高兴了。我们瞬间就恢复了默契。太有趣了。我们就是这样的。每个人都太棒了，我必须说，这让我觉得...
Miss the show? So much. Me too. Mm-hmm. Ugh. Ugh, well, anyway, if you're out there and you think that Craig and I should be in something together... Make it happen. We have good chemistry, y'all.
想念这部剧？非常想。我也是。嗯哼。呃。呃，不管怎样，如果你在外面，觉得我和克雷格应该一起演点什么...那就促成它吧。我们很有化学反应，各位。
Make it happen. We also got some fan questions about this song that we're singing. Cammie D and Virginia said, did you have to pay just to sing Everybody Dance Now? And Allie P from Atlanta, Georgia noted that Michael sang Everybody Dance Now in an earlier season, and Allie was wondering, did we have to repurchase the rights? Or did we choose this song because we already had the rights from an earlier episode? Well Steve Burgess said we did have to pay just to sing it, and we had to repurchase
促成它吧。我们还收到了一些关于我们正在唱的这首歌的粉丝提问。卡米·D和弗吉尼亚说：“你们为了唱《Everybody Dance Now》必须付费吗？”来自佐治亚州亚特兰大的艾莉·P指出，迈克尔在之前的某一季中也唱过《Everybody Dance Now》，艾莉想知道，我们是必须重新购买版权吗？还是我们选择这首歌是因为我们已经有了前一集的版权？好吧，史蒂夫·伯吉斯说我们确实为了唱它而必须付费，我们不得不重新购买
it. But because we just sang it and didn't hear any music, we only had to pay publishing rights, which were $17,500. If we had also heard the music, it would have been double. The day ends with Pam and Darryl returning to the office, and it's a complete disaster. Pam looks around and says, what happened? And Aaron charges past and says, pens happened. Yes, and then there's kind of a long pause
它。但因为我们只是唱它而没有听到任何音乐，我们只需要支付出版版权，也就是17500美元。如果我们也听到了音乐，费用就会翻倍。这一天以帕姆和达里尔返回办公室而告终，那简直是一场灾难。帕姆环顾四周说：“发生什么事了？”亚伦冲过去说：“笔发生的事。”是的，然后有一点长时间的停顿
and then Pam has the line, are the pens here? Did you improvise that? Lady, I did. I thought you did. I was gonna go back and check, but I'm like, that's the end of the scene button improv right there. When I saw it, I remembered when I did it in the moment, everyone really liked it and I was really proud
然后帕姆有句台词是：“笔在这里吗？”那是你们即兴发挥的吗？女士，是的。我以为是。我本想回去查一下，但我想，这就是场景结尾的即兴点睛之笔。当我看到它时，我想起了我当时做这件事的时候，每个人真的很喜欢它，我真的感到自豪
because I almost never improvised. And if I did, it almost never made it in the moment. Everyone really liked it and I was really proud because I almost never improvised. And if I did, it almost never made it in. It's fine. I'm very proud of this. Yeah, I get so tickled when any of that makes it in. Well, guys, there you have it. That was Suit Warehouse. Yes, big shout out.
因为我几乎从不即兴发挥。如果我真的做了，它也几乎从未被采用。当时每个人真的很喜欢它，我真的感到自豪，因为我几乎从不即兴发挥。如果我真的做了，它也几乎从未被采用。没关系。我为此感到非常自豪。是的，每当其中任何一部分被采用时，我都觉得太有趣了。好了，各位，你们看到了。那是《西服仓库》。是的，大力鸣谢。
Thank you to Matt Sohn for sending in all of those audio clips and to Matt Flynn for describing AppL athlete for us. And of course to Steve Burgess, who is always there for us, always giving us insider information, and to all of you for sending in your questions. We hope you have a great day, and we'll see you next week.
感谢马特·索恩发来所有这些音频剪辑，感谢马特·弗林为我们描述AppL athlete。当然还有史蒂夫·伯吉斯，他一直都在支持我们，总是给我们提供内部消息，也感谢你们所有人的提问。我们希望你们度过美好的一周，我们下周再见。
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwool, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Jordan Duffy. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwool、詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的资深制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是乔丹·达菲。我们的助理制作人是艾恩斯利·布巴科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。你。这个剧集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子来留下评论。